learn how to make games and JavaScript
using the Klay library in this course JS
Legend Dev will first teach you the
JavaScript you need to know to start
creating games then he'll teach you how
to create games hi everyone welcome to
this crash course where the goal is to
teach you how to program in JavaScript
so that you can start making games with
it so as opposed to all the crash
courses you find on YouTube on learning
JavaScript they usually teach you
JavaScript with the intent of making
websites and working in webdev now here
it's different because I'm teaching you
the barebones of JavaScript so that you
can start making games and then you can
start even watching my previous
tutorials which all assume that you have
a basic understanding of JavaScript now
why learn JavaScript for making games so
that's a good question you might have
asked yourself and yep I'm here to
answerer it so JavaScript is a very
accessible language it's a very ass
after skill that means that with
JavaScript you can work as a web dev so
why not use these same knowledge same
tools to make games and especially web
games so games that can run on the web
without having to download or install
anything and that's the first ADV
advantages of web games and using
JavaScript for making those games is
that you don't have to install anything
as a player which reduces the friction
it's especially an advantage in game
jams and especially an advant Advantage
when you're a new game developer trying
to build your reputation so by making a
bunch of smaller web games you can not
only build your skill as a game
developer but also uh more easily a mass
an audience or a like poent potential
players now the advantage of doing this
in JavaScript is because JavaScript is
the lingua franka I think that's how you
say it of the web that means that when
you make your game in JavaScript things
load fast and are Snappy so if I press
this is a game I made a Pokemon Style
game I made in JavaScript so I have even
like 60 FPS Etc so yeah if you were to
make the same game in unity which has a
web export it's usually bloated very
slow to start I have I had only bad
experiences playing Unity games on the
web now the other advantage of using
JavaScript to make games is that you're
not stuck on the web so if you want to
make a game on Steam you can relatively
easily transfer your game convert your
game into a desktop application using
Tori or electron or some other
Technologies I have a tutorial on my
channel teaching you how to make this
how to do that to have a game that is
written in JavaScript but works on
desktop a prime example of this was
vampire survivors which was a very
popular game on PC which was a web game
that was transferred into an electron
application so you can have PC game you
can publish your games on Steam so
that's another Advantage without having
to change your tools you can also do the
same thing for web uh for mobile sorry
so with one language JavaScript you can
make games for uh the web desktop and
mobile now the only missing part here is
the consoles and for consoles I don't
worry much about it because if you can
make a very successful game on PC
usually it makes business sense to just
um pay a porting house to Port your game
to consoles so as an indie developer
really should be focusing on making a
great game and if you want to make money
usually you have to go to steam to do
that and you can do that with JavaScript
and I would say the last Advantage is
the transferable knowledge you have with
webdev so imagine you're a new developer
you just started out you wanted to learn
programming and you learn JavaScript and
you realize like making games is fun but
I would not be able to make this a
sustainable career or something like
that well the tool JavaScript language
you learned is actually useful for
making web applications and websites so
the knowledge you have here is
transferable into in demand skill which
you can use as a software engineer Etc
so and vice versa if you're a web dev
already you might want to try to uh make
games and you cannot justify the
investment of time into learning maybe
Unity or good Etc so you might it might
be actually better for you to just stick
to JavaScript and make games with it and
there are many libraries you can use in
JavaScript to make things easy and one
of them that I teach on my channel cap
play is really uh really fun to use and
really quick to use that it makes it
very fast to make games with it so
that's uh that's that so what's the
promise of this video so by the end of
this video you should have a basic
understanding of JavaScript even if you
have never programmed before and you
should be able to have made your first
game so we're going to try to build by
the end of this video a first simple
game either a platformer or something
very simple and then after that you are
ready to watch my previous tutorials uh
I have I can show them to you here so I
have tutorials on how to make a Metroid
Vania game how to make a Zelda likee
fighting game GES
Etc and of course you can use other
resources and basically you can dive
into and then into it so after that if
you want to make uh go to webdev you can
follow tutorials Etc and read
documentations Etc so it's this is meant
as a gateway
to JavaScript but also like game
development in JavaScript so it's a a
gateaway to your programming career
maybe so let's get started so you will
need Visual Studio code here uh which is
the video uh not video the code editor
that I'm going to use you don't need it
you if you if you're not a beginner uh
let's say you're coming from another
programming language let's say python
you can use whatever you'd like that
that is a code editor like Vim or
whatever but I suggest that if you're a
beginner an absolute beginner you have
never programmed before you um pick this
editor so you're going to have the same
thing as me uh vs code by the way if you
don't know is really like the the major
uh code editor for web developers so
here I have a window that contains VSS
code so to open a new project you go to
file and then open a new folder so first
of all I recommend that you create a
folder and then you open that folder and
it's going to open it up for you here an
empty window with your empty folder by
the way I forgot to mention but this
tutorial assumes that you have basic
computer skills so that means you know
what a folder is ETC and uh yeah it
might sound surprising but for some
people it's not something that they know
Etc so usually if you if you grew on the
iPad you might not know what a file
system is how it works Etc if you're
used to any like real operating system
in the sense that uh it's either Windows
Linux or Mac OS you should be good when
it comes to following this tutorial this
crash course all right so what is the
shortest path to have your JavaScript
code running
so I'm going to open create a file by
clicking on that
button and I'm going to call it main.js
it's going to be the entry point of our
project of where we're going to write
our JavaScript code so by so I'm going
to first create that file write some
JavaScript code so here if I do you
might assume that you write your code in
that file and then you click on a big
green button somewhere to run the code
and this is not how we do it in the
JavaScript world so how you do it is you
need to create an HTML file uh I usually
like to call it index.html but it
doesn't matter you it has to be called
HTML so usually JavaScript is paired
with HTML and CSS which are other
programming languages they're domain
specific programming language that means
that they're not a general purpose
programming languages like JavaScript is
so let me explain just a brief overview
of what HTML and CSS are but I'm not
going to teach you them I'm really not
going to dive into it I'm just going to
teach you the bare minimum of HTML you
need to get JavaScript onto your web
browser and running so index. HTML so
HTML is a language used to make a web
page so describe a web page you have
many tags for example the first the
basic tag is the HTML tag which
signifies like that you're going to
create a document a web page and then
you have the body tag which is going to
not bot tag the body tag which is going
to contain the content of your web page
and Etc so the body tag the way tags are
written htmls you need those thingy and
then you have need to have a closing tag
an open tag and a closing tag and then
here the body is essential and then
within the body I'm going to put a
script tag which is the tag used to load
JavaScript uh yeah JavaScript files so
the way script tags work is that you
have the tag here and you have a source
attribute where you define where to find
your Javascript file here since we are
on the same level within the folder the
path is going to be
main.js so you could even remove that
and then do main.js if you were to
create a folder within that learn JS
folder which is the folder I created for
this project you when you created the
the the project you would have gone here
maybe open a folder and then you would
have a different name but feel free to
name it as as you want it does not
matter at all so if I were to create a
folder here I'm going to call it Source
or I'm just going to call it
code and then I put my main dods within
it here the path is going to be code SL
main.
Jazz so that's how it would work now the
first statement we're going to write
first code line of code we're gener
right it's going to be
console. log and as the name applies
it's going to log something the thing
you pass in within the parentheses here
to the console the console is in your
web browser when you press
F12 this is the console uh so if I were
to depending on your browser you should
have a symbol so here you have this
symbol console this is because I I
really have a big uh font so usually
would see them displayed here but since
the I've have increased the font so much
I need to click on the plus to actually
see the console here so if I this is the
console and this is where your the
output of your JavaScript code will
appear so now here let's say I want to
write a message to the console uh I need
to pass in what is called in programming
a string a string of characters
so bunch of characters that makes up a
string so hello
world is a string of characters so we
have the character H character e l l o
space character and then W so this is a
character even if it's not visible to
the eye uh it is a character and W etc
etc and it needs to be put within
quotation marks so now everything should
be all right but we still don't have a
way to run the code so the most the
basic way I would say is you would just
open this in a web browser and you would
get your your the result but usually the
preferred preferred approach is to have
a local web server that runs from your
computer that is going to run the the
code and display the run the web page uh
this local server is usually called
Local Host and there is there are many
ways to run one but the simplest way if
you're using vs code is to go to the
extension Marketplace type in Live
server
and you're going to get this extension
which as the name here launch a
development local server so you cannot
really see here so install it here you
should it should be written install but
since I have already installed it it's
going to right uninstalled so install it
once this is installed go back to your
project and then here below you should
see a go live button so click to run a
live server if you click that it's going
to open up a window now I'm just going
to
copy the
address because I'm going to open it in
this page so here we go so by the way
look at the description to have all the
links you need for example how where to
install VSS code Etc so here is the the
the Local Host server the address that
was given to
me and then click on that so by default
uh live server should open into your
default
browser but here I'm using a different
browser for recording this tutorial
that's why I copied and pasted manually
the address here now here we have a
blank page because I as I said uh HTML
is actually the language used to write
the content of a web page but JavaScript
is a language used to have animations
and logic Etc so initially when
JavaScript was created it would run only
on web page like that as supporting
character I would say just to add
animations to HTML pages so the the
actual web pages as the language evolve
and you could do more stuff with it it
is now possible to make games with it so
here we go so now I'm going to open up
the F12 the console tab you can also
open this console tab using I think
control uh command shift I if you're on
Mac OS but it's F12 on Windows and you
can see we can have our hello world
output message appear here this is the
console so we write our code in our
main.js file here and then it's going to
appear so if I instead of hello world I
say h Hello ogs
Legend and you can see that it updates
here so now we're ready we have our
programming our basic programming
environment ready later on we're going
to see more advanced tools and a
different setup that is more um closer
to what is actually what what's used
professionally all right all right so
now let's start actually learning The
Core Concepts of programming in
JavaScript so the first core concept I
want to mention it's the core concept
zero I would say is how code is executed
so I'm assuming that you have zero
knowledge of programming and then that
means like code is usually run as a like
a recipe imagine it as a recipe of steps
you need to follow and those steps are
extremely detailed because because if
you do not detail those steps the
computer will not know what to do it's
not like a human recipe for cooking
something where the instructions are
mostly General and the human can fill in
the gaps but with programming it's
different so code usually runs
sequentially so first line and then
second line third line
Etc so now that's like that's the basic
concept comes at zero but the actual
first concept we're going to talk about
is is variables and constants so what is
a variable and what is a constant so a
variable you can imagine it as first of
all your computer has memory imagine
Slots of where you can place data a
variable is you putting a sticker on it
with a name let's say my
variable and then storing into that cell
so imagine you have cells that could
contain data in your computer so it's
basic basically a representation of your
memory and then you pick one of those
boxes or those slots you put a name it
on it to know basically to be able to
tell it apart from the other memory
slots and then you put data in it so the
type of data you can put inside of a
variable are many you can put numbers in
JavaScript so that's the number type the
data type so you have data types those
are called data types for example I I
would put four inside of the slots
of the slot my variable and if I do this
and I again use the console.log message
and pass in the name of the variable my
variable it's going to print out the
content of that so if I look at the
results it's going to print
four at the console in the
console all right now the way you
declare a variable so you create a
variable is you need to use the let
keyword so you usually key important
keywords in JavaScript are in blue like
that if you're using VSS code without
any themes but anyway let is how you
declare a variable once you have
declared a variable you can call it
elsewhere but and you can even modify
its content so if I have my
variable and put five
instead then
console.log my variable you can see the
content is going to be different if I go
here first it was four at line two and
then when the computer arrives here it
modifies the content of the my my
variable and then we console log again
at line four and the content is now
different okay now there's a bunch of
questions that you might have is why the
name my variable so here when you
declare a variable you can basically
choose whatever you want as a name there
are certain symbols that are not allowed
for example you cannot use numbers to
name a variable so you will have
squiggly lines to tell you that it's not
allowed you cannot use dashes to name
your
variable uh however a letters from A to
Z you can actually use a z l so you can
use numbers I think
within uh mixed in with letters but
usually I prefer to keep
keep my varibles um actually can you
actually do that I I never almost never
do this so let's say z0 as the name of
the variable and then here and then so
I'm just going to remove it and see if
it works it should work but I'm just
making sure yeah so basically there are
certain names you cannot pick as well
you cannot call a variable letl because
this is a reserved keyword so those
reserved keyword in the JavaScript
language cannot be used to declare
variables and as you saw I wrote my
variable this is a convention that is
used in JavaScript code where when you
name a variable if you have multiple
words that comprise this name the name
of that variable then the the the first
letter of the second word used used in
that variable name always start with a
capital so for example just to show you
if I call my
variable name then I can just leave it
like that if I call it my
name I need to put the capital here it's
it's not the actual rules that means if
you don't respect this the code the code
will still run but it it but it's
against the convention which is called
camel case because it looks like a camel
you know so for example my
full name so capital here Capital here
like it it does a camel thing camel hump
I guess that's the name in English for
the yeah Ty animal the the thing behind
anyway so that's uh yep that's how you
declare variables so now it we saw that
you could put um you could put numbers
in it but you can actually put text a
string of characters as I said strings
we call them here I can put a name for
example
and then if you print that out so be
careful when you write your code to only
put like defined variables not uh random
names and then here if I look at the
result you can have like you can
see all right so now you know how to
declare a variable but you can do much
more than that than just declaring
variables you can also declare constants
so a constant is like a variable but the
content of it will not
change and there are some Nuance to it
later on but for now just keep that in
mind so for example I want to have as a
constant
um let's say the width the width of the
screen for example I would call it
screen width screen
width and then let's say 1080 this is a
concept it's if you don't want something
to change means if I try to change the
value scre with and then put something
else let's say
720 then if you look let me remove that
variable if you look at the console it's
not going to let me and you're going to
get an uncut type error assignment to
constant variable which means that
you're not allowed to change the content
of a constant makes sense right so this
so the general rule of thumb is that if
you're using a if you're sure that
you're not going to change so by default
what I do is that I always declare
everything as a constant only when I
know that I'm going to need to modify
the content itself of the
variable so the default for me is Con I
always use const unless I need to change
the the content of the the variable the
the the slot the the cell then I used
let to be able to do so
all right hope this was clear now let's
try to write something more useful so
let's say you have a
constant called okay yeah I have a
constant called number one and it's
going to hold five by the way when you
see me adding a semicolon this is
a this is something in JavaScript and
even in Java where you each time you
finish a line of code you write this uh
after its statement because there are
some other types of constructs in
programming that don't require the
semicolon but I usually prefer not to
use it because most of the it's not
mandatory most of the time so I usually
do this but you know just so that you
don't get confused uh if you try to use
other resources I'm going to from now on
always write the semicolon when it's
needed so const number one let's have an
a second constant number two let's say
four and then you can do math so let's
have another
constant and then we can have number
three or we can call it
result and it's going to be number one
plus number
two so this is basic arithmetic so it's
an addition and that means result should
contain
the nine basically so if I do console
log and I want to print out the result
and then look at the result here it's
going to be nine now the other way you
can do multiplication so to multip
multiply in JavaScript you use the dot
um the star symbol not an X symbol but
this one so now this should be
20 and it is and then you can divide
here by using the slash so those
operations are the same as math but the
symbols used are different so you might
not be used to them that's why I'm
telling you that like which is which
here
1.25 and then I think here uh that's um
yeah for now let's those are the basic
operations you can have exponents as
well so for exponents you use the this I
don't this symbol I don't know how it's
called so if I look at the result one so
uh wait a minute that's not that's not
right I think it's it's two two dot like
that yeah that's how you do expon
exponents so if you have let's say 2
exponent
2 2 to the^ of two it's four uh the
operation that I just did this is
something different and is I think it's
something different uh actually don't
remember but there's bitwise operations
but for now I don't think it's uh really
relevant for game de JavaScript for now
all
right uh okay so now we have you have
seen as a first core concept how to
declare
variables and how to change the content
of a variable but you cannot do that for
constants and that you can put numbers
and strings in them now what happens if
you have let's say a constant called uh
text and it has a string called hello
world and then you have a number let's
say four or number one I we going to
say maybe just number but I think number
is a reserved keyword maybe it's not and
what happens if I want the result so by
the way you don't have to store the the
the result of the an operation inside of
a constant or variable you can just do
it within the parenthesis here so text
plus number this in any other language
with a sensible type system
uh this should fail but in JavaScript it
doesn't it actually tries to compute it
and here it um it will do something
called concatenation so it's going to
concatenate for with hello world what
does concatenate means is that you if
you want to join text together join two
strings of character together you
usually use the plus sign for it so that
might be confusing because this is uh
usually understood as adding something
with something but adding text with text
how does that work so if I were to have
hello world and then I would say
hello world 2 you should have as the
result in a console one single string
with both of them so this how the
concatenation operator which use the
same symbol is
plus now the reason I said that it
should fail when a number and a a string
of character are added together is is
that it makes no sense you need to First
in for example python you would first
convert this into a character and then
you would concatenate it but JavaScript
doesn't have this thing and it's
something that it has been CR criticized
a lot uh so just keep that in mind to be
careful with those operations so don't
do that or if you're not if you don't
know what you're doing
so yeah this is cool and all but it's
time to actually learn the second I
would say or third core concept which
are conditional statements and this is
how like a program will truly like
become alive in the in the sense that
it's actually going to do a very
interesting things so we have a few
constructs we can use the main one is
the if
statement so an if statement allow you
to have conditional code code that will
execute only in certain situations for
example let's say I'm going to have a
variable this time and this variable is
going to be called um is
true as just a name or maybe I'm going
to call it
execute one other type I follow I forgot
to to mention is that you have something
called a Boolean type so Boolean can be
either true or false so here you could
have a true uh statement so true means
that it is true and the reason why the
true and false thing is useful here is
because it allows us to have conditional
logic conditional logic is code that
will execute only under certain
circumstances or do something else
otherwise so here in the if statement I
can have the execute pass in the execute
variable and now if execute is true it
going to run what's within the brackets
so here I can have a console.log
statement
console.log and I could say
hello and now if I look at the execution
the the result of the code you can see
hello
here all right now the issue here is
that let's have something more complex
so what if EX is false first of all you
put false in nothing will
happen so nothing will happen nothing is
happening now you can use this to have
more complex code so let's
say if let's create two constants let's
say if the age let's say
25 and the height is 182
so you can have you could have an
expression execute and then instead of
passing in a Boolean directly you could
do F
age is superior to or equal let's say
I'm going to teach you those symbols
they on this is like this is what we
call Boolean like comparison Expressions
I don't know if it's the actual term I
forgot but anyway so if the age is above
18 then it's is going to execute
here so you're an
adult for example and then here if you
put some code outside you're considered
a minor all right so here we go and now
if I run the code you can see though
both of them has executed because the
age here is actually above 18 so if you
want to uh only run this and not this
you would use an extension called the
else statement the else statement what
it
does is that if this condition is not
true it's going to run what's within I
mostly prefer not to use it so I'm going
to show you the alternative uh right
after so here we can can see because the
age constant was set to 25 manually at
declaration that's why I can you can
modify by the way a constant you can mod
ify it manually here what it prevents
you to do is to modify it later on like
age set a new age just make sure I yeah
this is UN understood so I said I would
show you an alternative to using an lse
statement what I prefer to do is to have
H actually I cannot do it here so I'll
wait before I before showing you because
there's another concept that you don't
have yet so you will not understand the
trick so basically for now else if you
don't want so if you want to have more
than one condition though for example if
you are here and if and then you can
have an else
if and then else if you can pass in
another condition and then have it
here so y so that's the the proper
syntax and then you pass in the the
condition here for example here instead
of putting this inside of a variable
which there is no need to it it was just
to show you you can put the expression
within the F statement it's usually what
happens in an actual code so if age is
superior to 18 or if age is equal to
18 uh equal equal but uh to 18 and then
you move here to so in certain
situations for example the if statement
you don't add the semic colum
thingy so that's why I I usually prefer
not to use it but anyway I'm going to
use it so here you have first if the age
is above 18 so I'm going to remove this
this no longer valid expression
JavaScript expression so if the age is
superior to
18 then it's going to print that if AG
is equal equal to 18 you could have
another message I say console. log you
just turn into an
adult legally
let's
go and now um if I go
here and modify the the content let's
say
18 you're going to see that you're going
to have a different message and you can
actually start making games like that
where you would change the depending on
what the player does you have different
constants or variables and then you show
different things but this is the basic
of an if if statement now here equal
equal that might sound strange so equal
equal means that since in JavaScript you
we use the equal sign to declare a
variable or store in it some value um we
need a different symbol in order to
compare if two things are equal and the
double equal is what's used but actually
that's not true what's used is the
triple equal because in JavaScript so in
any other Pro San programming language
you would for example python you would
have two equals to determine if
something is equal to
another and this is an error I would do
a lot so by the way just be when you
read when you start writing code you
need to be very careful that this symbol
is to store something inside of a
variable or a constant when you declare
it but the double equal is used to
compare things but in JavaScript
specifically you don't use don't ever
use this use the triple equal because a
triple equal the reason why we have a
triple equal is that if you have the
equal equal and let's say instead I'm
going to remove all of this and have an
if statement and have age equal equal
18 so here if it if this uh condition
actually occurs we're going to say I
don't know something like a BC it
doesn't matter so
here if we have this that means you
could have declared a a a string 18 and
then this is actually going to be true
and it's going to print out even though
this is a a string another a number so
if I go here it's going to print out
ABC and this is a problematic because
usually when you write this condition
you're expecting that age is a
number so that's why if you use the
triple equal which I was added later on
in JavaScript Life Time as it was
developed like years later it's not
going to print it out so the default I
always use triple
equal so now if I put back a
number it's going to actually work so
what triple equal does it makes sure
that the not only the values are the
same but the type is the same so the
type being either string number Boolean
Etc are the
same so I go here ABC is going to print
out
all
right now there's many different um
Expressions so when you use for example
you cannot do
this actually yeah you cannot do this so
when you're using above or equal
Etc uh you use um single quotation marks
um a single equal sign sorry with before
it the either greater greater than
symbol lower than symbol and also a new
one that you might not be uh familiar
with is the bang equal symbol so bang
equal means it's not equal and it's uh
if I go to here so bang equal the symbol
is basically like this you see ma in
math classes where you have
a you know this
symbol yeah it's basically that not
equal you can also have just greater
greater than itself and it means exactly
what it means
oops lower than
Etc uh yep and that's it so that's all
there is to it uh at the basic level so
just
to to summarize here are all the symbols
we've
seen lower and or equal greater or equal
greater lower
not equal equal equal but equal equal
stricter or which is you prefer this
over this so forget even that this
exists all right so that's uh that's
that now there is a yep so that's for
conditional statements there is another
type of conditional statement called The
Switch statement so the switch statement
is this and uh it takes in for example
your age and then it will match it
against Case
I prefer to so the cases must be
specific for example for case 18 you
have you write some logic here and then
you need to break out by using the break
keyword Etc uh I think as a beginner
don't really think of about it too much
you know you can write you just use only
if statements and you should be fine for
now later on at the end of the video I'm
going to point you to a great JavaScript
resources uh resource for if you want to
dive deeper all right now there is more
complex types of U data you can put
inside of a constant or a
variable and those are arrays and
objects so let's start with arrays so
arrays the way you declare them so for
example I usually prefer to do const and
then let's say I have a bunch of
numbers and I want to store them within
a single constant I'm going to use an
array the way you declare an array the
simplest way is to use brackets like
that and then for each slot you're going
to have an element so 1 two three and
then you separate them by commas so this
is how you you declare a
constant uh you declare an array sorry
so 1 two three this is my array it
contains the numbers one two and three
uh you can have arrays where you can
have one element uh one number and then
a string and a number again Etc but
let's keep it simple for
now so here we have an array and one
thing that is tricky is that you
remember when I said that the constant
means that you cannot modify this later
on that means you cannot later on in
your code come here and then change with
another array for example which say 1 4
6 this is it's not going to allow you to
do that however you can actually change
each um how we say each element itself
each the content of each of the slots
here this might be tricky because
constant you might think that things
must remain constant but here the array
itself is constant it's just the content
of the array that is changing so the way
you access specific elements of an array
is that you take the name of the the
array that you determined and then in
the brackets you put in the index so uh
the way array works is that the first
slot has an index of zero the second
slot has an index of one one the third
slot has an index of uh two and so that
means that the first element is not the
first index does not start with one but
with zero so here if I do numbers zero
and I print that
out you're going to have something
here so console. log and the numbers
equal zero if I look at it the the
results you can see one it's going to
print out the curve this one if I do one
as the index not the element the index
of the it's going to point toward two
it's going to print out two and then if
I do two it's going to be three so you
need to like really keep in mind that
these are the values the elements of the
array and these are the indexes so
basically the address of each of those
slots that contains one two and three so
if you were to use names instead just to
drive the point home so here we have an
array of names so I'm going to call it
names and then here you can have like I
don't know
John
uh let's say I don't have any ideas for
names here Max
maybe then
Chris you have three names and then here
those are strings basically and then if
you console. log names at index zero
it's going to print you John
John same thing if you do one instead
it's going to print out Max and so on
and so forth so max here
Etc all right so now that we have arrays
you can you know that you can have this
so how if you were to instead of putting
a cons to do let you could be able to
replace the whole array itself uh so you
could redeclare a variable like
that but here I'm putting an empty array
that means that when you're going to
console that log to the
console it's going to be
empty it's going to print you in empty
brackets yep empty
array all right so hope you understood
that how that's how arrays work at the
basic level now there are operations
that are available on arrays so for
example let's say you want to remove the
last element of an array what you can do
is you do names. pop
this is a function or yeah method so I
need to explain what a function is first
uh so you know what let's wait before
teaching you that uh those operations so
now you know what now I'm going to talk
uh call them operations because because
anyway console.log is a function that
you call me a
method uh but you might so I'm just
going to just for now call them
operations so there are certain
operations you can
have on arrays and one of them in
JavaScript is pop which removes the last
element if I go here you can see that we
have John Max but Chris is not no longer
there we have Push if you want to add an
element to an existing array what you
can do is use the push operation and
from within the parenthesis you can pass
in the the the next the element you want
to add to that array so here I could
decide to add uh let's say um
takuya and now here if I console. log
that uh names the name can see the array
is going to have now one two three four
elements you can get the length of an
array by doing Dot
length so this gives you the length of
an ARR this is all things Concepts to R
revise by the way because I don't think
you're going to remember them like that
if you don't use
them all right so another type of data
type you can pass you can in a constant
or variable is the object type so here
let's say I have an object
const my data I'm going to call it this
way you can define an object by using
brackets like that uh I always forgot to
put the semic column here at the End by
the way my editor will replace will put
it automatically for me that's why it
was always there anyway um here uh an
object can be think of like it's where
you can store properties and of data so
I think the best way is just to show you
an example so you have key value pairs
you def Define a key that you want to
use and then the value that is going to
be paired with it so for example let's
say we have a name you can decide on the
key name you you can write it out like
that without a string however if you
want as a key to use something that is
more than one word let's say name two
you need to put this within bracket uh
within U how you say quotation marks so
here because we're not using them within
we're only using a default name uh a
single no space
uh name we don't need and then you use
the two Dot and then what's come what
comes to the right is the value and here
what you can put here is the exact same
you could put inside of a variable or a
constant it's the same type of data so
for example the name I could decide on
John for
example and then here you need to always
put the coma the comma I think if you
only have one element you might not need
it but usually you use comma and then
you can add another thing age let's say
say 25 24 let's
say and then so on and so forth and it's
a handy way to store a lot a lot of data
so age um
nationality for example we can say
America or US
USA
Etc so what's cool with those objects is
that you can do my data so to access it
you can do console.log either you can
print out the whole thing using my data
so if I have the name of the object so
you're going to have the age the the
name the
nationality or you can print out
specific pieces here by using the dot
notation so dot and then you can see the
various properties so the age I just
want to print out the age you can have
it here uh one thing that is interesting
with um
object is that you can declare new
records or Properties by do using the
dot notation itself so I could decide on
a new property after having declared my
object so here I would call it
maybe
height let's say and then put an equal
sign and
then 182 maybe CM uh probably should put
it in an inch so let's say uh five uh
six six 6
foot so my data height 6
foot and then maybe it should be a
string here so 6
FD so now if I print out the console by
using
console.log the my data you can see that
a new record has been added let's see a
height you can see that even though it's
a constant like with the arrays it will
let you add new properties from within
the same array what it will not allow
you to do is replace the whole thing
with a new object so by doing my data if
you were to do this then it will not
allow you to do that so this is how
object works and I would say arrays and
objects are one of the most useful data
structures that you're going to use
there are others of course uh the reason
I decide not to talk about them here is
just not to overburden you with uh
complex and I'm really teach teing you
only the concepts you need to make like
your game a game simple game and then as
you going to get deeper you're going to
probably search and then find new
features new data structures you can use
Etc all right so now now that you have
this key value pairs Etc uh there's
another way actually I forgot to mention
that you can access properties uh from a
a an object you can do my data and then
pass in a bracket notation that is
similar similar to what you saw with
array but instead of passing in number
uh which is the index you can pass the
name of the property as a string it
needs to be a string here so so this is
especially useful when you have a
property that is two words for example
so for
example uh nice I don't know I don't
have any idea what to do here let's say
um years of experience years of EXP
XP and then let's say two
years and then here you cannot access
this by using the dot notation it's
maybe you could actually yeah you cannot
it's going to transfer you're going to
transform your the operation to a the
array notation uh I don't know what is
the the name of it but this is the other
way of accessing a specific property and
is mandatory when you have a property
that is a string in string form with
more than two more than one
word so you can actually use that way of
accessing properties this uh with the
other ones by just passing it as a
string instead age and then name Etc so
hope that was clear so the the next
concept I would say that is pretty
crucial to understand is Loops so Loops
allows you to repeat the same line of
code or multiple lines of code multiple
times this is very useful because it
will allow you to have to repeat stuff
and uh generalize so don't you don't
have to repeat yourself for example if I
want to print print 100 numbers I'm not
going to write console.log one
console.log 2 3 4 5 100 times that would
take me forever and this is where four
Loops come into handy so four Loops are
defined like this so for something so
for an expression condition do what's
inside here so for let's say uh this
where a
for let I equal z i inferior to
100 I ++ okay this might be strange and
I'm going to explain it so we declare a
variable that is going to act as a
counter the convention is usually to use
a single letter like I or J or something
like that that and then it's going to
contain so the for Loop contains three
Expressions the first one is the the
Declaration of that counter counter the
second one is the condition to look for
so for I inferior to 100 so as long as I
is inferior to 100 then it's going to
run what's it in there and the third
expression here is after running what's
in there it's going to increment so add
to the value of I by using the Plus+
sign so something I forgot to to to
teach is that let's say I have a
variable called number one and it
contains five you can add to it by using
number one plus plus that means the
content of number one is going to be
five uh another way you can do that is
doing plus plus equal and then one
that's another way of doing it uh you
can also do minus equal one or multiply
equal one if you want to multiply Etc uh
the long form of that is to do the
content of number one plus one that's
the the most verbose way of doing
it so just something to to yeah to to I
forgot to teach you all right so here so
if I have let I equal Z okay so let's
write something here so console of log
and I'm just going to log the actual
counter itself so here if I go here you
can see that it's going to run from 0 to
99 so zero because the count counter was
started at zero and 99 because you know
if I were to do one instead
here it's going to still run till 99 but
starting from one if you want to print
out numbers from one to 100 you need to
change this instead of being inferior
you need to be inferior or equal
so if I go
here you have up to
100 so Yep this is it so this is the
basic traditional way uh form of the for
Loop and now considering one thing let's
say you remember we had an array so
let's say we have an array of names and
you want to print out each name
individual so I have
John John Max
Chris and and we want to print each of
them using a for Loop so how would you
do that the basic way to do is to have
index I the counter to zero and down
here we just make sure that the index uh
the counter sorry is going to be
inferior to names. length if you
remember by using the dot length you're
going to get the length of an array and
here the length of an array is three
because there's three
elements so here in the console log I
can do names and then if you remember
you can pass in the index here so since
it start at zero and it's going to be
inferior to the length that means going
to be zero one and two maximum so if I
do here and I you can have John Max and
chis that's that is going to appear on
the
screen so in the console sorry so just
to illustrate what is happening is that
if I take this for
example and let's uh y so when okay I'm
just going to copy that that
code I'm going to go to the board here
going to paste it
here and let's let's zoom
in so what happens here is I'm going to
use the pen here so we
had three elements maybe I should
increase the font
size XL here you go so here
okay okay so if you remember we had
those three names inside of the array
and the for Loop what it does it's just
going to if I do the
execution it's I is first going to be
equal to
zero so during that first pass
names what's uh I is going to be
basically equal to names
with zero and if you remember the index
zero is the first index of the array
because we have one and
two so if we have I afterwards I equal
one names is going to be sorry for my
poor
handwriting one here so I mean name is
going to be one and it's going to print
out Max so the first time it prints
Chris uh John sorry second time it
prints Max the Third as the third time I
is going to be equal to
two and here so what happens is that I
is equal to zero we print out John and
then I ++ will make I equal now to
one and then here I is going to be equal
to one going to print out uh
Max here John
and then i++ is going to come into play
which is here remember and that means I
is now equal to two and then here I is
equal to two that means names square
bracket 2 is going to point towards the
Chris name so Chris is going to be
what's printed
out and i++ is going to make I equal to
three and now
we have I equal to 3
here and if you
remember we we run this as long as I is
inferior to names. length and names.
length means that the array names has a
length of three three elements that
means uh that this condition is no
longer true that means we will not run
the for Loop another time because I
inferior ior to
names do length which is the
array is now false equal to
false so hope that uh little schematic
uh drawing was clear all right so that's
how a for Loop works and now there is a
easier version of the for Loop that
doesn't where you don't need to think
like that uh this for Loop is still
useful in certain
situations uh but the easier version of
the for Loop is just to do here so const
name of names and then you can just
print out each of the names from that
array and then if I look
here at the result you can see that
everything was printed
out now this might be confusing because
where does name comes from so here the
easiest version of the for Loop is that
you create a constant called name but it
doesn't have to be name it can can be
any name here this is just a convention
because it makes more sense because in
the names array what you have for each
element is a name so you do const the
name of your variable that you just
created of and then the array and each
element is going to be assigned to that
constant and then you can refer to it
from within the for Loop all right so
now that you have the for Loop there's
's another loop that is very useful it's
called the while loop the while loop
what it does it continue continuously
print uh run the code within if uh the
condition is true as long as the
condition is true now it's equivalent I
think to a for Loop where you just do
empty expression here empty expression
I'm actually not sure if you can
actually do that in JavaScript so this
will run infinitely because it uh does
it run infinitely so let me test it out
I barely ever use this so going to do
this by the way something I'm just going
to teach you right now is if you want to
just for testing want to blank out
certain prevent certain codes from
executed can do control shift and it's
going to turn it into a comment later on
I'm going to teach you like what's the
utility of comments but comments are
things that are ignored by the compiler
so you don't so they're not treated as
code so basically it's a way to add
notes uh explaining why things are the
way they are in the code but you you
should not overdo it but this is the
utility and you can use it for to blank
out certain parts of the code you you
don't want to execute just for testing
purposes for example so if I do
console.log test just just to test what
happens and not I nothing happens so
nothing prints
out or maybe yeah it's going to actually
crash the the the browser so if I do
this I need to be careful I don't want
to crash
it and uh I think it crashed the
browser I'm just going to close it and
crash the web page not the browser but
so if I do
this
oops all right okay so it runs
infinitely
so if I just to show you how the while
loop is just a for Loop is if I have a
condition let's say we have let I equal
zero so like a for Loop
basically and then as long as I is
inferior to names.
length so I'm going to put back so I'm
going to remove it here I'm going to put
back the constant
so as long as name is inferior to length
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
console log the names. with the index so
the actual specific element and I'm
going to increment the
counter so if I do this you can see that
it gives you the exact same result as if
you were to use the for
Loop now one thing I just want to show
you is that if I were to do the same
with a for Loop instead so here I'm
going to comment out this one I'm going
to by the way hit control save
frequently and vs code to update what's
on the code editor forgot to to update
what the the code that is going to
actually be executed because live server
what it does is that every time you save
it's going to refresh the page and your
Local Host uh local
server so here if I instead of a while I
use a for Loop Loop and here I use the
empty thing so the expression I don't
Define it here I also don't Define the
other
expression I think it should actually
work the exact same way as a while loop
and it does all
right so just to show it but usually we
don't use uh a for Loop like that looks
kind of weird but we usually prefer to
use a while loop but I think go lank is
another programming language that
doesn't have a dedicated while loop they
just use the for Loop in the in the way
I've shown you I'm not sure about it
though I think it's that anyway so
that's how a while loop Works usually
for specific conditions uh you want to
check you want to run the condition as
long as the condition is false is true
or false you want to run what's in the Y
loop it's not usually used to what to
iterate through an array for example
this the terminology it's called iterate
through when you want to go through an
array and get every element so for
example you can make a calculation here
if the calculation is successful then
you change the like a a variable to from
True to false and then it stops running
so that's the use case for while loop
but for now you're going to see when
we're going to make our games there is a
lot of JavaScript features we're not
going to use and certain others that
we're going to use a
lot but I think it's a pretty important
construct so that's why I wanted to
teach you that all right I think one of
the most important Concepts is the
concept of the function so a function is
very important because it's actually
what allows you to uh have reusable
logic reusable code that you can instead
of copy pasting your code everywhere you
usually create a function by using the
function
keyword and then what the function
keyword does is first it's to declare
function and then you need to decide on
a name so here the name I'm going to
decide on is going to be I don't know um
let's call it let's call the function
add or addition or maybe uh you know
what let's call it add and it's going to
be used to add two numbers so this is
basic function so the function here what
you can use it the reason it's so
powerful is that you can see it as a
template so you can use a template you
pass in data here and then you put it
inside of your logic and then you can
adapt your logic to what you need so
here we're going to we need a function
that allows you to add any two numbers
any of them so here the parenthesis here
is useful because it's where we Define
the params params are parameters that
the function will accept and basically
you can think of it as a like tweaking
values so you can pass values to the
function to adapt it to your situation
so here let's say we have number one as
our first param so the way you define a
param when you declare a function is by
just call just deciding on a name and
then here I decided to call it number
one and then comma separate by a the the
the second param you want to use uh a
function can have no pams or it can have
one Pam two Pam Etc so it's up to you
here in our situation we want to be able
to add two numbers that's why I first
take the first number and then the
second number and then here a function
usually does can can either return
nothing or you can return a value so
here I'm just going to not return
anything but I'm going to console log so
I'm going to print out to the console
the result which is number one plus
number
two now here you need to be careful
because you could pass a string here
it's not it's up to you to be careful uh
if you were to use a typed programming
language that would be different because
you would have to specify the type so
for example if you were to use
typescript you would specify that this
should be a type number and the other
one as well so just uh keep in mind mind
that when you're using a dynamic
language a language that doesn't enforce
typing like JavaScript is you need to be
careful what you pass uh to your
functions or what operations you
do so there's a difference between
defining a function which uses the
function keyword and calling that
function so calling the function is what
actually executes the function defining
it it's like a variable like you have
the variable you can Define it where you
define the value and then you can call
it uh not call it but look at the
content of it or modify it by using
equal signs just the name without the
the keyword that comes before so here
for the function I declar the function
and then I can call it using add and
then passing one and two or three one
and two and what should print out to the
console is the result
three now one thing you need to keep in
mind is that while execution of code is
sequential so you have 1 2 3 4 5 6 Etc
step by step functions can be declared
in any order that means that it doesn't
matter if I call the function before it
is declared I think this should still
work so if I go I look at it it's going
to still give you the answer the reason
for this is because the way JavaScript
code is executed is that it first parses
your code and it's going to first like
look at the various functions you have
and parse them so it's going to
basically register them that they exist
so that's why it does not matter the
order of when you call that function so
I can call it before it is declared
because the the way functions are parsed
is not sequential but it's the code that
is executed sequentially hope that
distinction is
clear but usually I prefer you know to
First declare a function function and
then use it rather than uh you know do
this so now that we have that I need to
talk about return statements so as I
said a function can return something or
nothing here if instead of console.
logging the result I want to return it I
can do return and it's going to return
the the value so what does returning
mean that means it's going to just give
you the value so for example if I just
call the function here now nothing's
going to happen uh in the console
because nothing is visible however you
can do
console.log and
then call the function from within that
console.log and then you're going to
have the result uh not a number uh
that's not uh ah because I didn't pass a
The params we need so one and
two so doing this is going to give us
the result now why would you return here
is that it's not often the case that you
want to actually you know console log
immediately you might for example want
to have a constant result here call the
ad function let's say 1 + 2 and then um
and then with the result you want to to
have another call to the ad function
with a previous result plus let's say
two three again and then you want to
print out the final result so this is a
use case a very contrived use case but
it's a use case
nonetheless so that's uh that's it
that's how you declare a function how
you declare prams Etc that that's the
basics of it now another very important
part and another concept I would say is
extremely important is that we need to
know how what how things are passed to
the
function so there is something in
programming called passing by reference
or passing by value so passing by
reference is when let's say I have I
declare a constant number one
outside called five I declare another uh
called let's say four number for when I
call add here let's uh let's for the
sake of argument let's say you have a
let here and then let here as well if I
pass in number one and number
two and let's say instead of here of
just adding what I do is I actually try
to modify the content of number one if I
do instead of number one here it's going
to be like you know six and then number
two is going to be you know it's going
to be
five when I'm going to print
out um console. log number one and
console.log number
two if you look at the results you're
going to have five and four nothing has
changed so let's say even
like Let's ignore even this let's say
it's no longer called the ad function
let's call it modify I'm going to
attempt to modify these two variable you
cannot do that and the reason for that
is that what is passed to a function is
by value that means it takes the value
of your variable or constant and then
it's going to create within that
function a local variable called number
one and number two in this case that
means even if I modify it from within
the function it's not going to impact
what's from outside now this is tricky
because in JavaScript you can there are
certain things that are passed by
reference in a function so by values
when you just passed the value that
means there no matter what you do within
the function it's never going to modify
the outside content which is good but in
certain case with arrays and objects
it's actually going to modify the
content so that's something very tricky
let's say we have a single param which
is going to be an array I'm going to
call it my
array and I'm going to remove this and
I'm going to remove all of this as well
so this function modify let's say we're
going to try to overwrite the array by
putting it as an empty array and then
yeah just it just does
that now what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to Define an array called
actually I think
if I use const here like let's say my
array and let's say we have an array one
two three I think this actually might
prevent us from doing this because we
were using a constant anyway if I call
modify and pass in my array because
arrays and objects are passed by
reference if I console. log the array it
should be modify unless because I use
the constant it's going to protect it
against modification so if I do this
let's see
one two three and you can see that
nothing has changed okay that's
uh okay that's uh oh never mind um
that's not that's not it's it's normal
uh when you pass the array
itself it's not going to modify it so
you cannot modify the array so the array
is as if it were passed by value you
cannot overwrite the array uh the only
tricky part sorry if I confused you so
so it's passed as if it were passed by
value but however if you push that means
you add content to that array let's say
121 it's going to modify the original
array that mean that's why I say it's
passed by reference so if I go here you
can see that it added to the external
array here it added the number that was
added from within the um the modify
functions that means that the my array
here is not a copy uh it's not a
independent copy from the my array that
is outside of the function and this is
tricky because if you're not careful you
might be might think that you're not
modifying the array but you're actually
modifying the original array so you
might think that you're not modifying
the original array that it is safe but
it is not and operations like push pop
Etc modify the array the content of the
array even outside so that it's it's
passed by reference however you cannot
actually overwrite the aray so if I do
this it's not going to propagate so the
what's my array outside of the modify
function is still going to be the same
uh the same uh value so it gives you a
reference to it but if you remove the
content it's not going to propagate so
this is a trick tricky thing so if you
need to take an array from the outside
and do a bunch of operations inside of a
function what I recommend that you do is
you make a copy of that array so either
you can use uh the spread operator Etc
so the spread operator is something like
that so my
array can do
this I think this
should do the
trick does it from within an array that
so it takes the content of the array and
prad its element inside of a new array
the three dot dot does that so that's a
just something I want to
mention all right so now you've learned
about this Nuance you need to be careful
here um I think that we've gone over the
main I would say the Bare Bones Concepts
you need to
to learn JavaScript there's
one two last Concepts I would say the
first one
is local versus global variable so uh in
functions by the using functions you
probably like intuitively uh understood
the concept so if we have a function
let's say call it Main and you have a
constant outside John for example so if
you have a name called John you can have
access to it from the inside of a
function by printing name here so here
deprecated uh okay so that's something
with JavaScript so let's say my
name just to be different make sure that
the name is unique so okay so we have
here so if I call the main function for
example and look at the result you can
see John is printed out that means that
this what's declared outside is
accessible globally that means it is
accessible even from within functions
that are declare near near it or outside
so what that what that means is that if
you declare a function here
const uh my
name Max for
example then this this variable this
constant is not accessible from the
outside I cannot do console. log my name
here it's not going to work if I remove
this so actually just to test it out
it's going to print John but not Max but
the from within the main function it's
going to print Max
so it it takes the nearest Value the
nearest declaration so if I do this you
can see John Max so this uh you need to
be careful with this if you want
something to be globally accessible you
need to put it out outside if you want
something local you put it you declare
the the variable the constant from
within the function and this works the
same with if statement Etc so if you
have an if statement let's say I'm just
going to put it to true that means it's
going to run either way um if I declare
a variable call age and let's say 12
then console. log the
age uh this works but if I want to
console log the age from outside the if
statement is not going to work if I do
this age is not
defined so hope you understood this uh
the difference between a local Global
variable and how scope works so the
concept itself is called scope the scope
of variables and constant
so yeah so if you want to something to
be only accessible locally you declare
it as closely as possible as where you
need it so so that's that and then
finally there's the comments so in your
code you can add comments by using the
Das dash symbol and then writing your
text and usually comments are you leave
them for for others and yourself to
explain why things are this the way they
are and not what the code does because
what the code does you can read it
yourself when you first start
programming it's very difficult for you
to know what the code does you really
have to sit down read line by line Etc
but as you become a more experienced
programmer you can actually just it's
pretty pretty straightforward to read
piece of the code and understand what is
happening so useful comments are
comments that explain why things are the
way they are not how it works so why for
example you had to use this resolution
so you had to declare const with 1,000
something because this constraint and uh
we need to have this aspect ratio Etc
which is not clear to someone who would
read the code this is where a comment
adding a comment would be very
useful all right uh that's it I think we
have the basics concept down and then we
can actually uh there's one last thing
it's not actually a JavaScript concept
itself but it's very important is how to
modularize your code there are other
Concepts uh JavaScript I've purposely
left uh unexplained and not in this
course just so to not uh make it too
heavy for you as an introduction but now
this is very something very important
let's say you want to you cannot for
small programs you can write your Co
code all in a single file but as soon as
you become more your your projects
become more complex it it's going to
become time to be able to split that
into multiple different files and the
way to do that in JavaScript using this
setup is simple there's the old way and
there's the new way the old way is that
if you want to use multiple files the
way you do that is you let's say I
create another code file and I would say
for example UT tails. JS which is going
to contain a few functions that allows
certain operations like say number one
number
two so this is going to return the sum
between those two numbers numbers it's a
reusable piece of code I want to use in
my main.js the way you would do you
would import it in the old way is you
would go back to your HTML you would add
a script tag source and then the path
towards that
file and then uh don't forget the
closing brackets and then you would go
into your main Dess and then you you
would be able to call that function
where the is numbers you want so you'll
be able to use that function in that is
in the utils file from within your
main.js file so if I look at the result
you can see that it actually works now
this is the old way and this will
quickly become very messy as you go you
add a lot of script tags this is not the
the way to go because recently well
relatively recently there is something
called a JavaScript module so JavaScript
module what it allows you to do is to
use an import
sytax so instead of having your file
here uh you can just use the add
function out of nowhere like that
because you added the script tag before
and by the way with this old way the
order of which you import your script
tag is important because if you import I
think the script tag afterwards so let's
try it out just to make
sure if I do
code utils so let's say say I import the
utils the add function after declaring
now it's not going to work so here if I
look at the result you can say add is
not defined so that was one of the very
tricky things is that you need to be
careful with the order in which you
import you put your script tags so
that's really not the way to go I think
today so the way to go is to use
the JavaScript module feature which what
happens is that you specify a type the
type attribute
and what you're telling the H the
browser is that this type the the the JS
file is going to be of the type module
that means that you can use the new uh
import syntax so how does it work is the
following so I have in
.js I can add
export the export keyword and then from
the main.js I can do
import and then using bracket seed add
from utils you need to add
JS so UIL here is the
path the path where the function is
defined now here it's within brackets if
you just use the export but if you use
export default that means the only thing
exported uh the the named export is
going to be add directly so you're going
to do like that and now the add function
is going to be available and it's going
to run now the export unexpected token
export uh export default
uh why why is it not working
um Let me let me remove this let's see
if it actually
works UIL does not provide an export
name
default uh wait a minute so if I do this
like that okay okay so if you do export
and then you need to put this within
brackets
if I go to the result it prints out but
unexpected token export syntax error
.js if I go here okay by the way you
need to remove this otherwise you're
going to get an error so with this new
method you only need to import the entry
point which is the JS file the main.js
your actual this doesn't have to be
called main.js it's just the name you
decide on the entry point and then you
give it the type module when you're
importing it to your HTML with the
script tag and then you can have access
to the import syntax so you can in other
JS files you can do uh export function
Etc and then you can import with
brackets if you don't want brackets and
import directly you can have default but
I think you can only have one if you do
this so you might want to have a file
where you have multiple functions you
want to export individually you can use
the export keyword for them so export
function add export export function
multiply Etc but if you want to have
only one you can do a default and then
and you can mix I think you can mix so
you can have a default and then you can
have export function test let's say
let's say an empty function like that
and then that means here that while the
add function is going to be you can act
add it directly like that so if I look
at the result here you can also do a
comma and then have test as well as the
other name export you can use so if I go
here okay I haven't used it but yeah so
that's the the way to go uh I would say
all right so now we're ready to start
making games so and uh before that it's
time to just talk about what is a
library and I briefly covered it uh
later on uh earlier on sorry so a
library is code that is written by
someone else that you can reuse in your
own projects which allows you to not
have to reinvent the wheel and Library I
really like to use to make games is
called CAP playay by the way that's the
library and uh I have a whole crash
course that teaches you how to use it
all the the functions not all of them
but the main ones and you have a
playground where you can see examples
Etc so this a a really really cool
library to use to make games which
provides you with a bunch of things out
of the box to make games so let's use it
and make a simple platform
so here is where things are going to be
get different is that for now we have
written our code using this setup where
we create a local host server and then
with just index and HTML you can
actually uh start working on your game
this is all fine but this is not how
modern web development is done uh we
used nodejs and a the npm package
manager and a bunch of other flavors to
uh write our web code so I'm going to
explain how to set up that as well now
you could use K playay with just a
script tag the way you would do that is
you simply go to I think I need to go on
the
GitHub or in the installing K playay you
have the installation guide what you do
is you could have this thing here I copy
that and then you can basically have
that
here and then by the way even I just
need this first statement basically so
here I so the simplest way to import
capay is this so I'm going to just go
back to our main here can go here at the
top I can use the import statement using
native modules and it's going to import
the C player Library which is going to
bring you this capl name it's going to
import it from this link this URL which
host hosts the library as a MJS file
which is for module Javascript file so
now that you have that you can actually
start making your game so if I call the
capl
function which is provided by capl it's
going to initialize a canvas on your web
page so canvas is an HTML element that
allows you to work with graphics and
this is basically what you use for
making games in
JavaScript so you have here the canvas
now this uh this uh setup is all fine
you can start working and making your
games I usually prefer to download uh
the file at this link and then locally
put it in my project and then import
from that locally without having to rely
on the link being up otherwise if it
goes down one day uh your game will not
work but I want to try something
different just to teach you I want to
actually do it the way it web
development is done in the modern way
using
nodejs so nodejs is what you're going to
need to install on your machine it
allows you to run JavaScript on the
actual computer uh outside of the
browser now we use nodejs because we can
use npm uh a bunch of package managers
allows you to use a bunch of libraries
Etc but uh by the at the end of the day
our code is still going to run on the
browser it's just going to pass through
node.js it's going to be compiled into
JavaScript that can run on the web so
JavaScript that runs on the computer
using nodejs and JavaScript that runs on
the web are different they're mostly the
same but they're different and that's
why you need a compile step where it
compiles your JavaScript code that runs
in node.js and then compiles it to a
JavaScript code that can run in the
browser so the reason we did this is
because um in the past javascri no J
JavaScript uh implemented the JavaScript
standard I think uh more in a more
advanced way so it had a it implemented
new features faster I think and uh if
you wanted to have a nice development
experience you had to use nodejs to get
that and it would compile the code back
to JavaScript that could be used on the
browser which was less
Advanced so that's I think that's the
gist of it and but for really for this
you the only thing you need to
understand is that we need no JS we need
npm which comes with
nodejs and we need a bundler which is
going to actually do the work to
compiling the JavaScript code that runs
on nodejs into JavaScript code that runs
in the browser so this bundler is going
to be called vit and it's very like it's
it's it's newish and it's very like now
it's used everywhere so it's very
convenient to use and then after I teach
you how to make the platform I'm going
to actually teach you how to put it on
.io or some other how how to put your
how to publish it on the web and that
would be the end of this crash course
all right so now what I'm going to need
you to do is to install
nodejs so there's plenty of learning
materials and guides on how to do that
so I'm not going to do the installation
process with you so once you you've done
with you're done with it uh come back so
here we go in our editor I'm just going
to remove everything that we've created
so far so here I'm going to delete
everything
thing everything permanently and this is
where I'm going to open up the terminal
by
sliding my cursor here you could have
slideing here you're going to have the
terminal like that so now I'm going to
remove this I'm going to remove that I'm
going to remove this so we're going to
have only the terminal window here uh my
screen is big on purpose I don't
actually develop like that but it's just
for the video so that you can have a a
good view of things so if you have
nodejs installed you need to do node
uh-- version to see that you have
actually nodejs installed so here I have
version
20.11 I think the actual most current
version is 22.5 point1 so I should
probably update soon okay long-term
support so I have the long-term support
version all right so now what I'm going
to do is that once you have node.js
installed you have access to npm as well
and uh you also going to add have access
to npm based commands so here I'm going
to create the project so I have the the
folder learn JS which is the folder I
was in all that time ago and what I'm
going to do I'm going to do npm create
vit at latest dot so this command npm
create V at latest dot is a quick start
command that is offered by the vit
bundler which is what I've mentioned
earlier on and I use dot here so it's
going to use the latest version so
that's why it's at latest you can
specify specific version but I prefer
for this to use the latest version do
means that it's going to create
everything from within the folder we're
currently in if you wanted to create it
in its own folder you would type in a
name here that you want the folder to be
and then here if I press
enter it's going to give me a few
options so select a framework and then
here we're going to go with vanilla we
not we're not going to use react preact
Etc which are web Frameworks so going to
uh press enter on the vanilla option
using gar keys and then selecting then
enter and then between typescript and
JavaScript typescript is like JavaScript
with types it's uh it's becoming more
aitous I guess uh used professionally
because it makes your code easier to
reason about uh we're going to use
JavaScript for this project so by the by
the way if you know JavaScript it's
going to be easier for you later on to
learn typescript if you want to so now
that we have selected our JavaScript we
have a scaffold project so we have a few
folders and I'm going to go over them uh
here it tells you to run npm install npm
install is the general command to
install all the dependencies that are
listed in the package.json and
package.json is the actual file that is
very important to understand because it
defines your dependencies and the
various commands you have access to so
here our package.json have a name which
is the name of the project the version
you can decide it on which version the
type module this allows us to have the
import syntax uh using the JavaScript
modules this the import from and Export
thing here import from
Etc so package.json the scripts we have
access to is the dev script which will
run vit so typing npm run Dev in the
terminal we one vit which is the bundler
we're using which basically compiles our
code from JavaScript that is runs on NOS
in JavaScript that runs on the browser
now we also have the build command here
accessible to us which allows us to
build our project for the web this going
to be coming in handy when we're going
going to actually build the project and
uh publish it somewhere and then V
preview previews the build so Dev is
when in development preview is when you
have build the project you want to see
if that everything works correctly and
then Dev dependencies is the V bundler
tool
here so here there's not really much to
do except like we need to do npm install
so let's do that npm install in our
terminal it's going to install the
dependencies the the dev dependencies
probably yeah and it's going to add a
node underscore underscore modules
folder this nodecore modules is actually
where the code for the various libraries
you're using is going to be stored
usually you have a dogit ignore that
ignores that folder so git is another
thing you need to learn about uh I'm
going to leave this for another video
but git is very handy uh when you're
working on projects uh you you push them
to GitHub for example you have you can
have branches commits Etc allows you to
track your development Etc very nicely
I'm not going to touch the file today
I'm not going to explain what get is
today but I recommend watching a video
on kit uh I think you are watching a
video or reading about it it's very
useful okay so package. lock. Json is
not really important but it contains the
versions of each of our modules Etc but
package.json if you have a project
someone gives you a nodejs project and
has a package.json it's going to be very
straightforward uh you just uh npm
install it's going to list the
dependencies ETC so that's really great
now here we have an index.html with a
bunch of HTML that is irrelevant to our
project what I'm going to do is I'm
going to remove it everything I'm going
to remove everything I'm going to put
back HTML and the body tag by the way if
you want to go more into web development
I would recommend learning HTML CSS as
well more in depth here the script tag
we're going to use the exact same code
structure structure sorry I'm also going
to remove javascript. SVG with which is
just a logo I'm going to remove s. CSS
I'm going to remove counter all of these
are not necessary for a
project we have public uh as for the
public folder I'm going to keep it this
is where you put your assets uh but
actually it's not necessary for this
project I think we're going to do
without but let's keep it for now so
what I'm going to do is in
index.html um at the same level I'm
going to create a folder I'm going to
call it code like I did and here I'm
going to create our main JS file I
should have probably just drag and
dropped but because we're not going to
use any of the code I'm just going to
delete that one in index. HTML I'm going
to use the source as uh code
main.js and then as as the path and
don't forget to actually set the type
for this as a
module and then here I don't think you
need that um if I
let me just look at what was there
previously the original yeah it was
there so never mind so like we did in in
our simple setup we're going to do the
exact same thing here now you might be
wondering like why should I use npm well
actually you don't have to uh the reason
you would use it is maybe you want um
one of the advantage of using a bundler
that you can you do with npm is that
you're going to be able to have your
code minified into a single file which
is going to make it uh load faster in
the browser that's one of the main
advantages but otherwise um and also
it's going to be make your code less
readable to someone who wants to copy
you but even then minifying code is not
really a good security measure to
protect your code from reverse
engineering because since your code is
in the users browser there's nothing
pretty much you can do now now if you
want to
make a paid game I would just recommend
uh you know uh wrapping it as a desktop
app and I think you have more uh
security features but anyway I think if
anyone sufficiently motivated to reverse
engineering you reverse engineer you is
going to do it is going to be able to do
it uh but it it shouldn't be a a
showstopper I would say for example
there are many games where you have
access to this full source code for
example balatro uh is a game
made in Lua with love 2D and I saw I saw
a video on YouTube I think it was from
the Channel games from scratch where
the he he showed how you could have you
could access easily the source code
because if you use love love 2D which is
the framework that for making games with
love with Lua uh your code isn't really
protected you can because the way you
get the executable is just you zip your
your your source code and you do
something that transforms
intoe and then you can just open it up
open it back up as a zip or something
like that so you could see the whole
code of the the game but it did not
prevent balatro from becoming a very big
success in the gaming world so that's
something to keep in mind so here I'm
just going to add the type module as I
did earlier on
module here we come here we
go so now we have everything we're set
up now it's time to install the capl
library so K play is the library for
making games it was this one and for the
game we're going to actually
make let's do the exact same thing here
so here they show you how to do a basic
platformer in less than three 30 lines
of code so let's see so let's actually
do copy that code
uh I think we still need Onkey press yes
so it's going to be in mostly in jumping
mechanic probably going to expand a bit
on that but yeah uh that would be a good
first try with KL which is library and
then for more in-depth content regarding
this you can you you will be well served
on my channel I have plenty of other
tutorials by the way you don't have to
use KL there are many other libraries
like phaser uh by the way if you want to
use phaser uh you need to learn a bit
more about objectoriented programming
something I did not mention a lot in
this at all in this tutorial in this
course you can use also P5 for making
creative coding uh stuff very good and
it's I I Ed P5 to make this game by by
by the way you can watch a tutorial I
made on the channel on how to build this
exact game with P5 gz so that's uh just
to just to tell you that there are many
other options and it's not just that one
I'm not paid to to make videos on K play
uh so yeah it's just a library I really
like and that's why I've been using it a
lot all right so now um let's install
our library so to install K play you do
npm install C playay that's it and then
it's going to install it and it's going
to add it to your package.json here you
can see the in the dependency section is
going to add version
300.1 300 1.0.0 Alpha 191 so this is the
latest version of the KL library now if
you want to pin it to a specific version
by the way if someone else use your
project and just do npm install it's
going to install the correct version now
let's say you are watching this far into
the future uh you would do npm install C
play and then a specific uh AD Sign with
3,000 do0
do0 Das
Alpha 19.1 if you do that you're going
to have the exact same version now it's
nothing's going to change because it's
already the version but in case you're
watching this far enough into the future
you can use that to have the exact same
thing as
me so that's that's that all right so
now we have KL installed and we can go
to main.js and write import kep playay
from
ke
play uh ke play like that so when you
want to when you use nodejs you you use
the name of the library in strings not
the path of the library like we did with
the the other setup so now if I do capl
call the capl function one nice thing
about using Nos and V Etc is that you
have access to documentation when you
hover over over things like that that
you don't have when you use the other
setup I had so that's the one reason to
use it so we have cap which is which is
going to initialize our canvas so if I
go here go to the output
refresh okay relative must be
okay doesn't work for some reason
import
whoops oh okay I know why
sorry everything we wrote is fine the
issue is this just that now that we are
using the other setup this is no longer
relevant uh what we need to start our
local development server is that you
don't need live server anymore so you
can click on the go live button that was
previously and then it's going to
disable this uh the Local Host but to
run a server when you're using npm with
v is you do npm run Dev once you do that
it's going to start the server it gives
you the address I'm just going to copy
it and paste it into my browser as for
you you can just click on it with
control click and it's going to bring
you to the thing here here you're going
to get an error called favicon so
favicon I can use usually on HTML Pages
you need to Define an icon on top
because we're making games this is not
necessary and if you were to host a game
on edge. it's even more not necessary
I'm going to teach you how to prepare
your game for edge. I'm probably not
going to go into the it. iio thing
portal Etc and do the the steps but it
will just involve zipping your code base
uh zipping the build output and then
dropping it on h. that's it so we have a
canvas that takes the whole screen and
space so that's great now let's look at
the code here so I'm going to copy it
and I'm going to go over it so and I'm
going to explain everything so we don't
need this you can use load Bean I'm
going to explain why in an instant
so so if I look
you you can jump you see and now what
you can do is you can bring
forward squares rectangles Etc that that
are going to act as
obstacles now the way I'm going to go
about it is I'm going to keep that code
you know what just it might be confus
confusing for you so I'm just going to
write everything manual so capl is a
method uh not actually is the The
Constructor the the way to initialize
the canvas in so the canvas is the
canvas element is what is used to make
graphics appear on a web
page I prefer to hold it into a constant
called K because it's going to hold all
the what we call methods so methods are
functions that you can call from that
from a an object so remember I talked
about the fact that you could create
objects for example my object and you
could have properties and you know what
I forgot to mention but you can have a
property that that is a function so for
example you could have decided to have a
function called let's say um
add and you define it within like that
you can Define it either like that or
like that with using the arrow function
which is another way to declare a
function just to not confuse you this I
think is the better way so having this
like that is basically a method a method
that means you can from it's a a
function that this object can
call so yeah so that's a method so that
means that later on you could do my
object and then dot call the function
like
that so yeah might not be very
straightforward but that's how it
works so here what I'm going what I'm
doing is I'm creating the cap uh canvas
and I'm storing the context it's called
the context inside this K constant that
means that from now on for all methods
that come from klea you can do K Dot and
then the name of that method how I know
those methods is that you need to look
at the documentation so when a developer
creates a library uh they have multiple
an API a way of using it so an API
stands for application programming
interface and it's how to use what the
various functions and methods are
available or written by the LI the
library author that you can use in your
own project so what you're going to do
here is there are a bunch of of methods
and functions you can use and they're
documented inside of the documentation
in the docs section here you have
various names of reference docs and you
have the name of the various things now
for this tutorial you don't need to look
at that we're going to just do a simple
game I just want to you to have the a
quick win basically to have something at
the end of this tutorial and then later
on you can watch my K play Crash course
where I teach you more stuff in detail
or you can watch my other
tutorials so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to do a very simple game where
you're going to play a character and
it's going to jump over obstacles that
come from the right so think the dyo
game and you know the Google Chrome dyo
game if you when you don't have internet
connection so to do that that I'm going
to first pass in an object as a Pam to
the cap method the way why this is just
the way that this Library works and it
takes in properties that you can pass so
if you pass in an object with the
following properties it's cap is going
to do something for you so if I pass the
width property and specify width of
1,280 it's going to make the canvas so
the the screen where the game is
displayed width of 8 uh
12,080 uh yeah 100 uh 1,200 and 180 so
now if I specify the height as 720 we're
going to have a basic resolution so yeah
just remove that so the the code works
now if I go here you can have our canvis
here I'm going to keep it like that so
that you can see the whole game in my
screen like that now there's a bunch of
other options you could have passed but
I'm going to you know not explain them
here so here to load assets in cap you
use a load Sprite function but there is
a default called load Bean which is a
default Sprite that is available which
is the bean character you saw in the
homepage of KL which is this one this
guy so instead of you know uh worrying
about finding assets online Etc I'm just
going to use that for this project so
it's going to be easy to follow along so
now I'm going to create a game object
which is going to be our player so a
game object is an entity in Klay that
takes in uh that is created by using the
add method of the capl context and it
takes in an array of components those
components uh are offered by KL itself
that's why you can you need to use K Dot
and then you call them so here yeah so
okay and then using the Sprite component
I can display a specific Sprite since I
call the load Bean method offered by KL
I can call the Bean Sprite so Bean can
be called with this by passing a string
to the Sprite component with the the
string being Bean that's how now if I
look at this screen the the result
you're going to see a bean appear at the
top left corner now let's say we want
our Bean character to be at the center
so capl offers a way to change the
position of a game object you create by
using the pause component so all this
knowledge that that that comes from K
Etc K do it's not from JavaScript it's
from the library so there something to
keep in mind the separation between what
comes from the library and what our
Concepts from JavaScript is important so
here you can use the k. pause component
and then pass in either the width uh no
the x coordinate or the y coordinate or
you can call the center method from K
play for it to Center the um
oops to give you the position of the
center basically so here if I go you can
see that the character is at the center
and by by the way if if you press F1 the
F1 key you're going to have uh the debug
mode from cap which you can see like
various things but it's not very
important for now uh just remember that
if you're using Edge if you press F1 uh
it's going to open the support Microsoft
thingy which is not something we want
but you can rebind it by using uh I
forgot actually uh so yeah I'm going to
leave it for now like
that so now we have three components so
if I'm just going to display this in a
more readable fashion so we have two
components being used not
three and uh as I say the fact that this
is an array of elements this is
Javascript however Sprite pause Center
Etc are from Capa so this all these
components comp uh when composed
together gives us our player game object
now we're going to use the area
component which is going to create a
hitbox for our player a hitbox can be
seen as a square uh by default that
represents the body of our character
what part like what is going to be uh
susceptible to collisions so if I press
F1 again even though it will open it's
going to create a box here which is
useful because K play is to offer us
methods we can use and functions we can
use for colliding so by the way every
time I say method just just put in your
mind that it's a function
basically okay so
now we have this and then you can create
a body
oops we're going to use the
body oops component so now what the this
is a bit it's a bit not handy so my
formatter my code formatter does this
after five components or so it's going
to put them like this so it's going to
be more readable but anyway I use the
body uh component from kipa which is
going to make our game object
susceptible to gravity and Collis uh
yeah to gravity and collisions as
well so now we have if you just add this
like that uh to gra actually not to
gravity just collisions but
to have our player affected by gravity
you need to use the set gravity
method and here I'm going to put a
gravity of 1,000 so now if we look at
the result our Bean character is falling
down so we need to create a platform for
it to for the character to land on so
what I'm going to do is you don't have
to store your game object that you
create in a constant if you're not going
to use that later if you're not going to
call it later on so what I'm going to do
I'm going to just call the method the
add method directly pass in an array of
components I'm going to use the
rectangular component to just create a
rectangle and this rectangle is going to
have the width of the screen so I'm
going to use k. width which is a method
from KL that allows us to get the width
of the screen I'm going to have a height
though of um let's say I think 200 or
300 should be should be okay so now if I
look at the result you can see it's all
up there now I'm going to change the
position K do k.
pause and I'm going to put it at one Z
then maybe 300 maybe it's the correct
coordinates so by the way in Game
Dev by the way in Game Dev the farther
you go down the higher the value of y so
that's something uh very strange if
you're coming from if you're used to the
higher the value of y the more up you
should go so that's something you should
keep in
mind so here k. pause 0 through 100 I'm
going to put it at 500 and then I'm also
going to add an area component for the
same reason as the as I did um now this
is not really handy like cannot
apparently not see the whole thing so
I'm just going to reduce the font size a
bit
maybe you know what I'm just going to
keep it increase just so you can see
make making sure that you can actually
see so k. area and then K do body are
two components we're going to
add whoops did it add it no
okay so now the only difference here is
that in our
array we're going to have to pass an
object and specified is static property
to being true
so what this is is that the body okay
you see now it properly formats it so
what happens here is that KL has the
body
component which takes in an object and
the object you pass in can take can
Define the IST static property and IST
static if you set it to true what will
happen is it going to make your uh
platform your game object not
susceptible to gravity so it's ideal for
Platformers for platforms so if I go
here you see it lands perfectly now I'm
going to add an outline to the platform
and you can do so with the outline
component and specify a thickness here
is thickness of three should be okay
and you land on the
platform all right so that's all good
and all now let's implement the jumping
mechanic for a player so you can do this
um
here so you can have player and then
here you can have an Onkey press Onkey
press is a method offered by K play that
is also available when you create on the
game the resulting game object that you
create so on key press takes in as the
first param the key you want to uh
listen on and it's going to be the space
key I decided that so when you press the
space key you can uh it's going to run
the function that is passed as a second
parameter so here because I didn't teach
you the arrow function the arrow form
this is another way to write a function
because I didn't teach you that what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to do
Define the function from within here so
you define a function here uh let's say
um actually never mind when you want to
just have a throw away function you
don't want to spend time on naming it
Etc you can use the arrow function so an
arrow function can be defined like this
you pass in you you have the parenthesis
and then you have an equal sign and then
a greater than sign which gives an arrow
and then you have brackets here so if
you were to if you want to Define an
arrow function out side you would store
it inside of a constant or a variable
usually constant give it a name and then
do like that so that's another way to
define a function this the there is a
Nuance to the difference between using
the function keyword uh meaning
declaring function like this with the
keyword and using the error function but
I think for now just consider them the
same for now later on I'm going to point
you toward a great JavaScript resource
that you can use to deepen your
knowledge regarding that so here what
happens is that when the space key is
pressed which is what passed as the
first Pam the Onkey press method is
going to run the second function it's
going to run the function past as the
second Pam by the way you can pass
functions as Pam to other functions so
you canot not only pass in numbers
arrays
objects strings Boolean
you can also pass in
functions which is pretty
handy all right so now what I'm going to
do is write the logic so I can just call
the player from outside remember the
global versus local thing because player
is outside of the function definition we
can actually use it from the inside so
player Dot and then you can use the jump
method uh from K play which is uh
offered when you create a game object
with I think the body component so now
if I go back to the game and I press
space you can jump now you can see that
you can jump infinitely because we need
to actually make sure that the player
can only jump when the player is
grounded otherwise they can just fly off
like that which is not uh which is not
what we want so what we're going to do
here is we're going to have an if
statement so this is where it's going to
come in handy so this if statement by
the way if you have an if statement that
you the logic you want to run within the
if statement is only one line you can
you don't have to have the brackets like
that you can actually just you know do
this put everything on one line like
that so I'm going to do that so if the
player is grounded this is a method
offered by K play that tells you if the
player is grounded what it returns is a
Boolean value it says written here
Boolean that means it's it's going to
return either true or or false and if
you remember this is exactly what we
want in an if statement because if this
is true then this runs if it's not true
then this will not this will not
run so if I go back I will only be able
to jump while I'm
grounded so now the only thing left is
to have obstacles coming from the right
and then as soon as there is Collision
we are going to basically enter a game
over
state so here we go now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to have a loop
function so K do actually can use a k.
loop I think that's the
name so the loop function is something
from K so you the first param is how
many seconds so every time so every one
second
it's going to fire the function past as
a second
Pam so by the way if you have any
questions uh things you don't understand
feel free to ask them in the comment
section I think uh I've have tried to
teach programming in a few hours uh to
someone probably who had never uh
written a line of code in our lives so
if you're this case you might still be
confused because we we're doing a lot
we're speed running through a lot of
Concepts so you still need to practice
those uh basic Core Concepts that I was
teach taught you but now you actually
have a base from which to further your
knowledge so that's something you you
know what you don't know basically you
can you can you know where to look for
information Etc you know what terms to
use in your Google search so that's
something pretty cool as that is going
to help you a
lot so here the loop every 1 second
we're going to spawn a game object that
we're going to create here that is going
to be a rectangle let's say 50 by
oops using direct component is going to
have a position of I don't know what the
position would
be
um let's
say what happens if we go 200 by 200
I'm just going to see it it's it's going
to put you here so if we increase the
value of x we're going to have let's say
8,000 and even more
1,000 and then here we're going to go
down so we need to increase the value of
y if you remember why because the the
higher you go in values of Y the lower
you
get okay so here I see it here it's bit
too low and by the way I'm going to add
the area
component I'm going to add the body
component and I'm going to add the
outline component by the way the order
of the components does not matter in
Klay and you're using the KL
Library so here we go and now what I'm
going to do yeah so it's increasing in
place which is not what we want but it's
pretty cool
Factor that's pretty nice it's
unintended but really
cool so what I'm going to do is after
having this I'm going to actually have a
move the move
component is you just determine the
direction so the direction at what speed
so the first param I think it's the
direction so you use a vector two so
Vector 2 is just an X and Y value it's a
data structure offered by capl and and
it's very useful for specific specifying
coordinates Etc so here the vector 2 is
just going to be let's say one zero and
then the
speed do you need to specify the speed
yeah the speed is a second per R I'm
going to explain why one zero in an
instant here the speed let's move at 300
speed let's see now it's well more it's
it's better formatted I think I better
like like this for format unfortunately
it
gets to this point after a while by my
format which does it yeah
automatically okay
so okay so here the the vector two is
used as a Direction so the X Direction
and then the Y Direction so the X
direction that means going to move in
the direction of uh X1 means to the
right so if I want this to move to the
left it needs to be minus one for the Y
AIS we don't need to move in any
direction and then it multiplies this by
the speed which is 3
300 here we
go so we have our now our jump is a bit
floaty
so so maybe if we did the game as
instead of uh dying as soon as you get
hit what if the game was you have those
box appearing and the goal is to survive
and not be pushed outside of the bounds
of the of the of the thing it's going to
be a nice Twist on the dino game so here
I'm going to reduce the grav uh reduce
the gravity to maybe 800 so I have
reduced the
gravity uh it's still a bit too floaty
to my taste maybe I should increase the
gravity not reduce it let's put 8 1,000
2,000 i''s say let's say 2,000 should be
a good
value all
right yeah 2,000 is
nice now we could you know have a speed
that
varies so let's do that so let's have a
couple of different speeds the the boxes
can move towards so here I'm going to
Define an
array oops const speeds and then I'm
going to have either 3,000 or you move
really fast at 500 or even faster at 800
and then the way I'm going to Define
when to choose what is I'm going to have
a random selection so in JavaScript you
have the math module which is Avail
available by default you just do math
and then random is the method I'm going
to use it's going to give me a random
number from 0o to one now here I'm going
to do the selection logic here so uh
current speed I'm going to call the the
the constant and I'm going to pass it
here current speed so you can see how
declaring constants and variables is
useful to make your code more readable
so here current speed what I'm going to
do is I'm going to select the speed by
using you remember the brackets here to
select a specific index and it's the way
we're going to select the index that is
going to be a New Concept here so if I'm
going to use the
math.
random method so it's coming from the
math module which is from JavaScript
this time around uh you have this axis
by default there's nothing to import
it's going to give you a number between
zero and one and then you multiply this
by using the remember multiplication is
with a star symbol by the length speed
speeds do
length you remember you could get the
length of any array by using a DOT
length uh yeah the dot length now this
is not going to give you a whole number
that's why you need to use another math
function called math
floor and you need to put in parentheses
because we're going to pass all of this
as a
peram and it's going to make sure that
the number is round so it's going to
floor the number so if it's 0.5 it's
going to be zero if it's 1.5 it's going
to be one Etc it's going to floor it
that means we have a whole number here
which is going to act as the index so
now let's look at the result here we go
you see the speed
varies and then
as soon as we go off screen we going to
lose so now it becomes a the time before
you
lose so here we can add different speeds
so what's nice about this piece of code
is that it is it scales regardless of
the length so I can add continue to add
elements and the code is still going to
work this one so that's something that
you really want when writing code is to
have code that can be adapted that
adapts to the
situation uh when you can do in when you
are in situations when you're able to
have code like that this is really great
this is great code so here I'm going to
let's say
2,000 let's say one to
4,000 let's see how it how easy or
difficult the game
becomes okay it becomes too fast that it
doesn't impact the gravity system like
the physic system struggles to handle so
let's add 1,1
1,500 here we
go all right so we have a game now the
last steps is to maybe add a
timer and
uh
oops add a timer and
yep I'm wondering if it's too easy
though
here we
go okay so let's have a
timer so the way to display text is the
same thing you use game objects and uh
yep so basically we could use this to
have a counter
outside so const counter let's say
zero and that would be the
score and the the longer you stay within
the bounds the higher the score and
every time this Loop is going to run we
do counter
Plus+ which is going to run uh increase
and then here you could add at the top
left corner so what you can do is uh
basically create a actually you don't
want to create a game new game object
what you can do is you create a game
object here
const
counter
UI and I'm going to use the add function
here I'm going to use the text property
and because by default game object are
positions are positioned to the top left
corner I don't really need to specify a
position or anything you I can just add
a text here zero so the text component
is from Kay it takes a text so I'm going
to just going to put zero here and
then what you can do is after
incrementing you can have counter. UI
and then have access to the text
property and then you can modify the
text with a new C counter now remember
here it's a number and usually you want
to do like two string using the two
string method to be like
really uh how we say to really be in the
correct the do the correct way however
JavaScript it works to just transform as
a text put as a text the the number
directly because remember um if you do
the plus sign it's going to concatenate
so yeah so just you know just put the
counter here and if I go here assignment
to a constant variable remember uh we
cannot what do you mean constant
variable uh okay so this needs to be
transformed into a let a variable
because we cannot increment it
otherwise and then that should work so
you see at the top left corner you have
three four as the loop starts oops and
then I lost so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to have the game over
condition so what happens is we need to
in the player logic there's actually a
component called the
offscreen component so if I go
here here at the end of the player
definition If I Do offscreen by the way
use the line numbers to find yourself
there's this offscreen component that
means if you it's going to track when
you're off
screen so now here here which going to
which is going to allow you to have
access to a new method called is
or when the off
screen is off
screen that's a Boolean that's not what
I
want um what's the the
function is off screen on Destroyer on
exit
screen so this method is going to take
in a function as its peram and it's
going to run that function when the game
object leaves the screen so here you
what you can do is um display message in
the much the same way uh using the text
component working at big fonts like that
is really not handy because it it hides
the actual code so I hope in your editor
you don't have those behaviors though so
here game game over
so at the top left corner it's going to
display game over now if I let myself
beaten game over you can see now you see
the score continues though uh which is
kind of strange but um it's not what we
want basically what I meant um so what
happens is we can decide that
um we could
Define so I I don't want to complicate
things um so what we could do is Define
a scene so in KL you have scenes uh the
way you can Define them is just by
calling the scene method pass in a name
you want to use for that scene game
over and then the second param is going
to be the logic that is going to run for
that scene and it's going to be an arrow
function or here it's more handy to use
an error function as a so Arrow
functions are really useful in K play uh
maybe I should have taught them at the
beginning anyway uh I'm in a moment I'm
going to teach you the I'm going to
point you toward a really great resource
for JavaScript so yeah uh you're
probably going to learn
everything at once there anyway so I
named this scene game
over and what happens here you can
instead of displaying the game over text
here you can display it here
put a position k.
position component call from within the
center function method from Klay which
is going to Center the game object and
then here in on exit screen I'm just
going to do K.O which is the method used
to go to a specific scene and I can go
to the game over scene like that so now
if I go here and I let my save Pon it's
going to be game over and then you need
to refresh the page to play the game
again now that's it that's the game and
uh hope you learned a few things and uh
yep it's pretty fun to to play it's a
bit too easy though so you can tweak the
values but at least you have your first
very first game now it's time to teach
you how to export that game how to uh
publish it so the way you're going to do
that uh the simplest way put it on it. I
which accepts web export or game jolt
those websites the way you're going to
do that is you're going to first open up
the terminal again and then here you can
use control sorry this is the terminal
window you can use control C to cancel
uh the the server you started uh
terminate terminates the the server I
think in Mac OS it's command C or
control c as well I don't I don't
remember well it's been a while since I
haven't used a Mac so now here you're
going to run npm run
build now if you run npm run
build it's going to transform this and
build it for production and it's going
to create this disc folder now to to
check that actually it actually works
the build the output you're going to do
npm run um
preview which is going to preview your
build it's going to create another Local
Host I'm going to copy the link though
manually because I'm going to put it on
my edge browser and it works you see now
what you have to do is you simply open
this in your file explorer zip those
into a folder these three
things and then you can just drag and
drop them in the .io thing so h. iio
have their own guide on how to uh
publish uh the web you just have the zip
file and then you that contains the
entry point the
index.html the assets and uh basically
the your your output you just put it
there that you set it to web game web
export and that's it that's how you
publish your game uh how you get it
ready for
production so now what are the next
steps so you've learned quite a lot and
maybe too much and it's time to you know
relax and also talk about the next next
steps so here is my channel so I make
JavaScript and typescript Game Dev
tutorials mostly and you can see there's
plenty of tutorials that you that are
now accessible to you that you couldn't
do before because you didn't know
JavaScript as all and so I recommend you
can go here but what I recommend more uh
at first maybe uh is to actually no you
can watch my tutorials uh immediately
after this one but you can also check
this interesting resource called the
modern JavaScript tutorial which
contains everything about JavaScript
classes error handling things promise
promises a syn weight something I did
not cover at all in this project in this
sorry this crash course but is very
present in my tutorials I I think I
spent some time uh explaining it but not
all the time not in every tutorial
so that's something you can I recommend
you just look through and I think it's
going to really round up your knowledge
and what's really great about this
resource the javascript. info is that
you have a search bar so you can search
specific Concepts so for example if I se
search
promises I'm going to get specific like
the specific text that explains how it
works now yep so this resource along
with the mdn
MDM M mdn web
docs Mo yep these are I would say the
highest quality docs you can find
regarding JavaScript hi everyone welcome
to this new video and today it's going
to be a crash course on the Klay Library
so Klay is a library for making games in
JavaScript and in this video we're going
to go over the various concepts of this
library and it's not going to be the
usual Project based tutorials but if
you're interested in more Project based
tutorials uh where you learn the the
concepts as you go feel free to watch my
previous video so I have pre prepared a
list of Concepts and things I want to
talk about uh regarding K playay so this
video is more meant to be watched as a
something that you watch passively and
you refer to later on so here we go so
first of all I'm on the KL GS website
and this KS website is very important
because this is where you're going to
see the documentation and access to the
playground Etc so it's not fully
complete yet so before continuing I need
to explain more in detail the origin
story of Klay so Klay was previously
called Kaboom JZ and Kaboom JZ was a
library for making games which was
maintained by repet if you watch my
previous video on the topic where I
explain why the Rebrand you're going to
see that there's a bit of context here
but for now it's the same thing as
Kaboom but with just a new
name so let's jump right into the um
installation process so to install K
playay there are many ways and I'm going
to talk about three ways and I think
there's two ways or yeah I think there's
like two ways mentioned here or three so
anyway I think both the three ways are
going to be mentioned so you can use a
package called create K play to create
maybe I should increase the font size
here we go so you can use
a a package called create capl to create
to scaffold your capl
project and uh I personally don't use
this method uh simply because it uses es
build as the bundler and you have to
refresh manually your browser to see the
changes I prefer to use vit which is
another bundler but this option if
you're a beginner you're just starting
with npm and you don't know this uh
bundler Etc it's a very straightforward
way of using so it's a CLI tool so if i
y so I think this just will Point
towards uh the package on npm so if I
open that up you can see the various
options you can add typescript you can
even add uh Tori which is a technology I
used to make the desktop game tutorial
uh which was the previous video on the
channel and that's that so you have
examples you can start with an example
Etc so very it's Can it can be very
handy just one thing I don't like about
it is the fact that you have to refresh
manually the the
browser now you can use a CDN this is
the second option and this option I like
it and I've used it a lot for my
tutorial because it's very easy to set
up so if you don't want to use nodejs
and you just want to use basic HTML CSS
and JavaScript well you can use this
method so this method how it works is
that you point to this link and here you
have the version and then yep it will
load the the file I usually prefer to go
to that link and then download the file
itself instead of just pasting the link
here but you can do both and the
advantage of this method is that really
it's uh dep dependent from node and it
will actually work I think if you don't
I think it's more maintainable in the
sense so what I mean here is that if I
don't touch the project like in five
years and I come back it's going to
still work exactly the same there's
nothing to update Etc because it it
freezes it takes a specific version Etc
and then you but you can also do that
with nodejs but you don't have like the
node thing you don't have to install
node Etc so that's the advantage
so here it's using the module type uh in
JavaScript so it's a JavaScript
JavaScript n native modules so you can
do both here either the old way where
you just load the thing here this time
around you need the GS instead of the
MGs and then you use it in another
script tag or another JS file that you
load through a script tag or you use
this new method newer way of having a
type module with all which allows you to
use import statements
and then finally it's the um npm way
with vit where you first need to install
V and then you use npm install K play
and then you can specify a version by
using this notation here and then here
there's a it's a bit more complex to
explain how to do it uh but if you look
at any my uh web developer as a game uh
portfolio my my portfolio game tutorial
or even I think I used it in the Tor
tutorial where VT is used but I think
you should really refer to the uh build
a developer portfolio as a 2d game
tutorial on my channel which really goes
through how to set up uh K playay with
well Kaboom but it's the same thing so
with
V all right so now that we know how to
install K play how do you deploy your
games so this is a question that uh you
might be wondering how to answer and
then depending of course on the tool you
use it's going to be different but for
the simple the simplest way the CDN is
you just zip that file and zip your your
code base basically and then put it on
.io or on GitHub Pages Etc as long as
there is an index.html file it should be
very straightforward um not going to
really dive deep into how to do this
here um I think because maybe it could
can change in the future depending on
the tools you're using so if you want I
could write a blog post on it uh by the
way I make written tutorials on uh
substack which is my newsletter you can
follow Link in the description so if you
want more written content and the place
of written content is that if you want
to learn how to do something specific
it's very it's more convenient because
you can easily refer back to a text
rather than a video and for more Project
based tutorials this is better as a
video because you know I can just show
you how to build a project from from a
toz and it would take too long to write
it out now this video I'm currently
recording is the exception because
normally this would be in a text format
but because there is a lot of content I
want to cover I would never have the
time to write it out so maybe I will
write parts of it uh in the future as a
written content all right so now that we
have covered how uh the various ways you
can install K play Etc let's go to the
playground so the playground is
basically an editor that you can use
online without having to install
anything just to try out capl so here
you can see that capl is imported by
default you don't see the import
statement that's uh that is something
specific to this playground but in when
you're using vs code you'll have to do
like cap play from capl Etc so how do
you initialize the canvas in a Play
Project well you call the K playay
method uh function sorry and then this
Klay function has various options and
let's dive into those options so of
course I need
to increase the font size like that
sorry so that you can see I'm assuming
maybe you're watching this on mobile and
yep so here we go we have a a big text
so let's write it out so here the play
function takes in optionally an object
which you can specify a bunch of params
by default the canvas when initialized
will take the whole uh available space
however if you want to specify specific
width and height you can do so using the
width property for example
[Music]
1,280 and the height I'm going to use
720 and if you do that and refresh well
because I'm zoomed in a lot if I do
zooom I get maybe
a with yeah I refresh so there's a bug
with the the playground at this size so
yeah
sorry can I increase the font size
anyway you can see that it takes
uh the the appropriate width and height
however if you want your canvas to be
scalable in the sense that it will adapt
its size regardless of the window size
Etc you can use the letter box option
which will make sure that the canvas
will scale
accordingly but while remaining
retaining the aspect ratio so you do
letter box true and it's going to add
black bars uh elsewhere when when
uh when there's nothing to but so what I
mean is that if the as long as the
aspect ratio is respected so if it it
would it will not expand further
otherwise it would violate the aspect
ratio so this is how you get a scalable
canvas that retain an aspect
ratio now there's also something a the
debug option by default it is true is
said it is set to true and allows you to
open up debug mode by using the F1 key
now now here I recommend that when you
finish your kabo uh capl sorry project
you set it to false so that you prevent
the player the end user to be able to
access this debug mode which is done by
pressing the F1 key so here I can I have
can I modify the
font font zoom in okay and then if I
just put the window as it was initially
C I'm going to
refresh and then here so I just
discovered this
font zoom in and then you can you have
to do this manually yeah can I have a
shortcut
font recently used editor font zoom
in okay I'm just going to set this up so
that I don't have to zoom in the window
the whole thing uh
so I think it's using the same uh
underlying editor as BS
code okay let's do this more
quickly I think that's fine all right
now it's it's very nice okay so you have
the width height layer box and debug
option and now the other thing I want to
mention is the global property so by the
way let's first look at debug mode so if
you pre you click on your canvas press
F1
uh oops I need to First remove this this
part which is invalid code right to here
press F1 nothing happens oh because I I
set it to false so by default it's true
so when you do not specify it's going to
be true and then you can see the FPS
counter and then you can see hit boxes
when we going to use that so for now I'm
going to set it to True uh but when you
finish your project I really really
recommend that you do false here now the
last option I want to talk about is the
global option property and I usually set
it to false what this means is that if
you set this to false playay methods and
functions can only be utilized uh I mean
true sorry I want to make it true by
default it is false but if you make no
never mind sorry I'm confused myself
it's false because we don't want it to
be Global so if it were Global which it
is by default is that you can use Klay
methods and functions outside of this
context however if you set Global to
false all Kaboom uh Klay methods and
functions must be used through this so
you do K dot the name of the function
and the method
Etc okay so now that I have covered this
let's uh show you how to load Assets in
capl so loading assets I think there's
an example we can take a look at and uh
let me just look it up so I don't have
to find new assets to show you um Sprite
Atlas Sprite maybe it's the Sprite
example by the way use this site it's
very handy it has a lot of examples you
can look at uh
okay particles shaders
bright post effect
RPG
Bene
okay all right so
now we have this okay
so it's not what I want
now here we go all right so this is the
buil-in Sprite example and it really
shows you how to load Sprites so here
ignored the C things here you can also
set of scaling and a default font which
are other options but I felt it weren
wasn't very important the scale is
somewhat important but the rest isn't
because um loading a default font you
can just do this elsewhere you can load
the specific F when you need it under a
specific text component later on we will
be looking at the various components we
need so the most important part here is
the load part so here uh since K play is
used globally and without a context we
can just immediately use the load Sprite
fun uh method however if you were to use
the setup we I've shown you earlier you
would write const
k.l I would put the global here to being
false and then here I would have to do
k. load Etc but I will not like redo the
the whole thing the whole example um you
know what since we have the the link
here let's do it so that you you really
understand everything so I'm going to
remove all of that and I'm going to show
you so here we
so first of all I'm just going to paste
here the the link towards the the Sprite
so I don't have to look out uh look for
another Sprite sheet so first of all
let's import let's use the let's
initialize our
canvas and then with a const K Etc now
if I uh hit control s when writing code
it's going to be like this
now what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to set the oh I'm just going to
set the
global property to being
false and that's it so and then now I'm
going to start use loading the Sprite so
k. load Sprite is the usual method you
use to load assets there's also Sprite
Atlas but I don't think you'll for now
I'm just going to present the load
Sprite function because the Sprite Atlas
is when you have a Sprite sheet with
various an image with various Sprite
sheets in the same image and you want to
cut out specific portions and make them
their own Sprite sheets so this is what
it is useful for maybe I'm I'm going to
dive into the the example that uses
Sprite Atlas later but for now it's
really important to understand how to
load the Sprite sheets and or just basic
Sprite so you use this load Sprite
method and then the first param it takes
is the key you want to use so it's a
name that you're going to use use in
your code to refer to that Sprite here
I'm going to call it Dino because it's a
dinosaur and then the second param is
the path towards that image in your file
system in your codebase but here we
already have something provided by the
playground so I'm going to use that and
then for now you could use both these
two prams and call it a day so now I'm
going to create a game object I'm going
to talk about more what game objects are
in Kaboom later on but I'm going to just
actually I don't even need to assign it
to a constant but just to keep it simple
to create a game object in K play you
use the ad method and then you pass in
an array of components those components
are provided mostly by K play but you
can create your own custom components so
one of the offered components is the
Sprite component and you pass in as the
param the name of the Sprite you want to
display now if I hit control save you
can see the whole Sprite sheet has been
displayed here by default when you
create a game object that isn't a in a
position uh you don't specify the
positional component it's going to put
it at the top left corner now here it's
where it's handy to maybe have the scale
property here and scale it four times so
that you can see it better so this is
the whole Sprite sheet now what how
would you go about setting specific
animations so here you have an optional
third Pam for the load Sprite at uh
load spr method where you can specify
the slice X property and the slice y
property the slice X property basically
you tell it how many uh frames there are
in the x axis horizontally so one 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 nine there's nine frames so I'm
going to have nine here and then slice
Y is going to be one because there's
only one um uh one
um one frame per uh row I guess per
column so here we go by default it's
going to take the first part and cut out
the rest now how do you define an
animation well you can have the anims
property and then here you choose on
name so here I'm just going to do the uh
running run animation I'm going to call
it run and it's another object and then
you specify the two the front key which
is the initial frame it's going to be
frame zero to the last frame which is
going to be frame index 8 because in cap
play um
okay wait a minute why is it highlighted
this way from two okay so one one thing
one thing I need to mention is that here
uh frames are computed have a number on
a Sprite sheet that always starts with
zero so it's zero indexed so here 0 to 8
is actually nine frames so now what I'm
going to do is now that you have this
you can in the Sprite component uh pass
a second param and specify an animation
and you use the Run animation name and
then you can see here now here by
default the animation will only play
once and then stop you can use the speed
property uh not the speed sorry the loop
property to Define if it runs only once
or it Loops infinitely so now it loops
and
Finly now there's something wrong with
the animation it doesn't look that good
uh so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to do this I'm going to comment
that out I'm going to comment that out
as
well so we
have jumping
Landing jumping and then like that so
it's a strange animation I don't see
where where is the beginning and the end
so is this is this only one animation I
think it
is okay never mind animation is fine
it's just a a some a dinosaur that will
jump and
then jump again I guess anyway so I'm
going to put it back and
then I'm looping it but this animation
clearly doesn't seem it is designed to
be looped but anyway you can also
increase the frame rate here I'm going
to have a 10 uh speed of 10 and then for
example the higher you go for example 60
it's very fast three frames per
second very slow Etc so yeah so feel
free to configure that as you see fit so
this is how you load Sprites in KL how
you load assets more generally uh there
are other methods to load assets so for
fonts if I go to the font example is
there is there one text
maybe you can see that you can load a
font by passing in the key you want to
use and then the path to it and that's
it and then there's two types of font
there's the bit map font as well which
you can load which is an image of
characters and then you specify the
width and height of each of those
characters so those are your options
when it comes to fonts now so for except
for images Etc images and
uh text and there's also audio that you
want to learn how to load you can use
the load sound method and then here the
same structure the the the name you want
to use the key then the path towards the
the sound
itself and then you can also here that's
for loading for playing though you Ed to
use the play
function the C playay function this you
shouldn't confuse this with the play
Method later on I'm going to see for
playing the animation so one thing I
should have shown in the
Sprite example is that you can specify
the animation by default in the uh
second paramet of the Sprite component
but you can also call a play Method on
your game object so maybe later on I'm
going to show an example so for playing
the sound you pass in the name the key
and then as the second Pam you have your
options you can pass as well optionally
you can decide whatever to Loop or if
it's paused and even the volume you can
set the volume or you can adjust the
global volume by using the volume method
in K play all right so now let's uh look
at some let's write our own code so I'm
just going to take the shortest example
possible here and just redo everything
so cons k k play and then your
global global
false all
right so now one other thing I want to
talk about is how scenes work in K
playay so now you know how to load fonts
now it's time to look at very how to
manage scenes so by default what you see
on the canvas is the default scene
however you can specify specific scenes
so so the way you do that is by using
the scene method in Klay it takes as the
first param the name you want to use
this is a pattern that you see often
where for a lot of those things like
load Sprite load font load bitmat font
load sound Etc you have the first param
which is always the name you want to use
for that specific thing you're creating
and then second param is the path but
for here uh for creating a scene the
first param is the name you want to use
let's call it uh test scene and then the
second param is going to be a function
here it's preferable to use an arrow
function because it's more Compact and
the code within that function here is
going to be the logic for that scene so
here uh one thing I want to show uh
showcase is that in K playay there is
default Sprites you can use and one of
them I think it's the only one available
can be accessed by calling the load Bean
method and then you have access to let
me create a game object here k.
Sprite adding my first component
here and then here I'm going to call
it
um Bean well by default when you use the
load Bean method its name is going to be
Bean so now if I refresh this we aren't
in that scene yet that's why nothing
appears on the screen here in the Klay
uh initializer I'm going to also make
the scale four times so things are
clearly visible and then here to go to a
specific scene you do K.O and then the
name of the scene and here you can see
the bean character so now if you add
another scene k.
scene um so test two and then you could
have another here and then here I could
use the
add uh method and then add this time
around a text component and hello
world so now here instead of going to
test two I'm going to go to test one so
what you can do for example is that we
first go to the test scene then we by
using the wait method in KL and we can
just wait 3 seconds and then go to call
the following function
K.O with test two so now if I put test
here refresh so one two and three
seconds and then it goes to the other
scene so here how it
works so this is how scenes work in
KL now let's look at how game objects
work in Klay so game objects are I would
say the core concept of Klay so
everything is game object a game object
is created as I mentioned earlier on by
using the ad function ad method uh and
usually the way you do it is for example
I create a player a game object and I
use the k. add and then it takes an
array of components that is going to
determine various behaviors and
attributes of that game object and those
components later on we're going to watch
the I'm going to talk about the major
components that you're going to need
when you're making a game there are many
of them but I'm going to uh talk about a
very specific subset so here you use the
ad function and pass in a an array of
components and then here for example I'm
going to create a a player the the way
the components I usually use for the
players first is the positional
component so I specify a position on the
canvas so let's say 100 by 100 I usually
I usually do this last but I've always
first start with the Sprite and if there
is no Sprite you can use the rectangle
component which which is just going to
draw a rectangle which is going to act
as our base uh our placeholder Graphics
I guess and then here I also can use the
area component which creates
automatically a hitbox for our player
you can configure it later on so when
I'm going to talk about the major
components in K play I'm going to do
that and then here so rectangle Etc so
if I just do this you can see a
rectangle appearing here and if you
press F1 you can see the hit box here
so this how you create a game object uh
optionally also you have another option
uh instead of just adding it directly to
the
scene what you canot do what you can do
is use the make function so make what it
does it will create the game object but
not put it on the scene so you have to
later on in your code do a k. add
yourself and then pass in the player
reference and then it's going to add it
this is useful in certain cases where
you want to create uh make Constructor
functions that will make the The Entity
for you and then later on add it to the
various scenes you want so I prefer to
use ad most of the time though and then
after you create the ad after using the
ad function it it passes it returns a
reference to the game object that can
store in a variable or a
constant and then one thing I want to
showcase is that you can not only pass
just components but you can also pass
objects which you can use to add custom
properties to your the game object so by
default if I do this and I just
console.log the player we we're going to
be able to see the shape of
a um well actually where where are
console.log supposed to appear in the
playground so yeah so maybe like if you
use this H console lot instead of log so
now it should appear in the console yeah
you can see so here I'm just going to
increase the font size so you can
clearly see so here it's an object and
then you have the various methods
available so you can see that there is
the add method in the player because you
can add children to game objects so you
can do player. add and then create
another game object as a child and then
you have a bunch of properties and stuff
like that that are default basically
provided by Kay uh for example the width
or the position screen position you can
access the position property for example
if I I I want to know what is the
position of the Cur the player currently
I can just do player. pause and it will
appear you can see here x 100 y 100 okay
so now that you have a basic
understanding of what a game object is
and how to create one um let's let's
actually give you an example of a child
game object so if I want to create a
child game object what I'm going to do
do is I'm going to take for example the
player and use the ad method again this
add method this time around is from the
game object and not the global one the
one from cap but they work the same way
so I can create another rectangle game
object 10 x 10 however the position for
example I can also specify the area if I
want and then here the
position what is going what is special
here is that the position is relative to
the parent so if I do 0 0 it's going to
appear on on the parent by the way I'm
just going to change the color you can
do so by using the color
component and you can use that uh
specify RGB values but you can also
specify hexadecimal values by using the
color from hex and then passing in the
hexadecimal code but here just to keep
it simple I'm just going to do it 0 0 0
so it should be black
and you can see it's on top of the the
parent game object now if I offset this
by 10 you can see it going to move to
the side 20 Etc but it's relative to the
parent which is very useful and so the
cases where you want for example let's
say you have a player you have a player
with a a weapon that turns around them
and follows them so you could have you
implement this this
way all right so now now it's time to
introduce the major components uh so the
Sprite component was the main one I
wanted to talk about the first one
actually so let's say I have my
player and then I have my bean so I'm
just going to load the bean here load
bean and then here I'm going to do k.
add and then here I'm going to use the
Sprite Bean here as I explained it's a
default Sprite available in K playay so
that's why I'm using it so I don't have
to search online for a Sprite sheet uh
there's also the Sprite sheet I've used
in the dino example which is available
in the playground so you can use that as
well so here I used the Sprite bean and
then well actually I'm going to need an
animation otherwise it's not going to
work so I'm going to just copy this and
paste it just so I can have two
instances of the playground where I can
see the code so in the
Sprite just need the path
here then if I go back here I'm going to
just load it load the assets properly so
load
Sprite
dyo and
then the path and
then we said slice X is nine there's
nine frame nine frames sorry slice Y is
one because we have one frame per column
and then the animation we only had one
so anims and then here I'm going to
specify the Run animation by the way as
long as you don't have you have single
word at properties you can just use you
don't have to use quotation marks then
from zero 2 8 and then let's Loop the
animation Loop the animation so by by
the way something I probably forgot to
mention I'm just going to use Dino
here is if I
just y put that in here so this is frame
zero one 2 3 4 5 6 7 and eight so it
starts from zero just wanted to show it
visually so you don't get
confused
oops okay so now let's say we have our
Sprite player Sprite here let's add a an
area to it a positional component as
well let's put it at 100 by 100 so the
first param is the x coordinate the
second param is the y-coordinate sorry
if I didn't mention this earlier on so
here we have our Sprite if I press F1
you can see that the hitbox is slightly
taller than the Sprite itself and this
is where you're going to need to twe
tweak it yourself
so let's talk about the area component
as well so the area component you can
change it shape by passing in an object
and then specifying the shape property
and you need to use the re Constructor
so you can use new. k. rect this is from
KL and this is going to specify a
rectangular hitbox the first Pam is
going to be a vector two so another
Common Sense concept I need to talk
about but usually Vector 2 in K is just
an X and Y values just as a data
structure that holds an X and A Y value
so here you can create a vector 2 like
this by just calling the component
itself and then here I'm just going to
put it at 0 0 because this first param
of the rectangle is just going to
position offset relative to the game
object I don't want it to be offset it I
just want the position to be the same
that's why I put a zero here so it's
going to be 0 0 uh it's not going to
change it's not going to be different
from the original 100 by 100 position of
the game object the player game object
and then the second Pam here is going to
be
a the width and the height of the hbox
so the width is going to be let's say
let's start with 16 by 16 and then if I
press F1 you can see that it's a bit
taller that's why here you can actually
decide to offset this by 16 and it's
going to drop down so 16 is too
much by the way in game development the
farther you go down the higher the value
of y the yeah so the farther you go now
it might not be intuitive but yeah
that's the that's how it works so here
we have our hitbox that is relatively
well POS positioned you can decide
whether or not to reduce the with maybe
to
12 and then push
the the hitbox forward by
two and or maybe three or four let's
let's starty four four is too much so
let's start with three so this tweaking
game is what you need to do to really
have set your headbox
correctly uh all right so you have your
hitbox you have the player okay
everything is fine
and now just to show you you can play
animations by doing player do an uh
playay and then specify the animation
name you could have done this in the
second param here as the default
animation but just show you if you have
multiple animations you can switch
between them by using this so play and
then the name of the animation so the
animation is going to to be a dino no no
that's the Sprite sorry the Run
animation sorry and then you have the
animation play all right so that's how
you you use the area component and the
Sprite component now there's also the
body component and the body component is
used to have collisions so while the
area component creates a hitbox it will
only make sure like you can check like
overlap between your game object and
other game objects using the UN Collide
methods but you can use the body
component to uh make it solid or
affected by gravity so let's using the
same example let's uh add a platform
right below so I'm going to create a
game
object uh under which is going to be the
platform I'm going to use a rectangle
I'm going to set it to be 1,000 of width
Maybe 1,00 by
50 I'm going to use the area component
it's going to perfectly fit the
rectangle so I don't need to specify a
custom shape as for the position I'm
going to set it to zero as the X and
here maybe 400 as the Y maybe it's too
much so
100 100 is too okay too much 150 okay so
we have our platform here additionally
if you use the area component you can uh
use the uh so if you use the rectangle
rect component and the ARA component
together you can use the outline
component and then specify an now line
so with a boldness of three for example
now there's a lot of things like that
happen in K playay where you cannot use
certain components if other components
are not added to the component array
here so you're going to have an error
message that is going to tell you what
is wrong so you can easily fix it so now
here in our player so here I did not
assign it to a constant because I don't
need it uh it's just a throw throwaway
platform game object
so here let's say I add the body
component so by adding the body
component it's going to be affected by
gravity but you can see that nothing
happens that's because you need to set
the gravity and by the way in the scene
example I've shown earlier you would
write all this logic not the asset
loading logic but for example this logic
inside of its own scene so let's do that
just to to be like clean so I'm going to
define a scene I'm going to call it game
you can Define it however you'd like I'm
going to pass in this as a second par in
the function and then here I'm just
going to include everything we have
here inside so now and then finally
don't forget to go to that scene from
the main context from the the the root
so game so basically this does the same
thing I just wanted to make things clear
so maybe I have to reformat this
code oh no that's what that was mistake
here we
go okay so now for the gravity you
usually need to set it I you cannot set
it there are certain things that you
have to reset from scene from within the
scene so if I try to set the gravity
using the set gravity method offered by
cap and set for example to
1,000 actually works okay so it works uh
so you can set the gravity outside of
the the scene so that's good so if you
want to have a global gravity that is in
this all levels you can do that once and
then Define your code so usually this
function you might need to if you want
to organize your code later on you would
create a SE a separate file and then
import that function and then pass it
here as a second param for example so
now you can see that our player just
passed through the platform that's
because we need to also add the body
component to the platform itself however
this is where A New Concept is going to
occur is that you see both were affected
by gravity but if you want to use
platforms Etc you need to specify a
param from within the body body
component and here this Pam is called is
static and you need to set it to
true so here you can see that our
dinosaur is on the platform so by
default the body just adding the body
component and specifying a gravity will
make the the the game object dynamic or
affected by gravity so it will fall but
you can specify an option called is
static from within the body component
and this is going to make sure that the
game object is going to remain unfaced
by gravity and it's going to act as a
wall basically or a platform in that
case all right so that's it and then
let's look at so I've already talked
about major components like the color
component uh to change color the outline
components I've also mentioned the
rectangular component the text component
you have seen me use it yeah let's dive
into the text component a bit more so
here is an example that used like G
global K playay so without having global
false Etc uh one thing I want to mention
is that after you have loaded your font
here is the basic usage so I'm just
going to try to just just going to take
this copy
this create a new example I should have
not done that actually I
realized can I go back no I cannot okay
let's uh go back to rewriting our
example cons K instead of using the
second type I had open to just pick the
the things I needed I just lost my
progress so here
Global false
and then here I'm just going to paste
the statement I had here I'm just going
to add K in front of it so I'm going to
load the flower sketches font flower
sketches. ttf that's the the full path
and then here just to show you how to
use it I'm going to create a game object
and use the text component so you need
to create a game object to be able to
use the text component you cannot just
call k. text I don't because you need to
also specify the position of that text
for example by default if you don't
specify it it's going to be at the top
left corner but here let's put it at the
center this is how can do with the
center component something new uh here
it's undefined for now because nothing
like we haven't specified a text here so
here you specify the content of your
text as the first Pam I'm just going to
modify
this oops modify this to be clearly
visible um more like pretty I guess uh
usually my code editor takes care of
doing this but since I'm teaching this
whole crash course on the playground so
I have to do it manually so here let's
type in hello world as our default text
if I do this you can see that you have
our hello word at the center but you can
see that it is the origin of the text is
going to be at the top left corner by
default game objects have their origin
at the top left corner what if you want
the origin to be at the center so that
the hello word position is actually
going to be centered the text is going
to be centered this is where the anchor
component is going to come into play so
here you need to use the anchor
component you need to specify an area
component beforehand so here by default
it's just going to make a hitbox around
our text and then right below you can
actually the order of the of the the
components you put them in the array is
not important you can put them in any
order it's just that usually I prefer
like you know I use the text component
the array component I usually put put
them in the order of usage but you're
free to dis place them however you you'd
like all right so now what I wanted to
do is we have the area okay
now I can call the anchor component and
then you can specify the anchor to being
sent
and this way the origin is going to be
at the center now our text is centered
you can have top left top right but you
can also use a vector twos so by calling
Vector two you can specify a specific
position uh maybe that maybe was an old
Behavior I don't think it's what this
works here so forget that but here we go
so hello world
Etc now now that we have hello world uh
what I wanted to do is to show you how
to change change the font so you can do
as we saw in the example have a default
font here but I don't prefer to do this
I prefer to change the font per text
component so here as the second param
you can pass an object and then specify
the font name by passing either font
property and putting the exact same key
key here we use to load our spread so
here's the the font uh it's a flowery
font I'm going to you can also increase
the font size by
doing adding these the size I think
32 maybe
64 yeah it's the
96 hello world so that's the font all
right maybe the background by default
you can set the background being like
black here we go you can do this but
usually I prefer to create a game object
that takes the whole screen and then
just change the rectangle's color that
rectangle so this game object rectangle
is going to take the whole screen
because if you use the set background
method offered by KL it's going to um
color everything and if you use the
letter box King I mentioned earlier you
will not no longer have the black bars
it's just going to be the same color
even though so it's going to look very
weird where your Sprite character for
example will move offscreen but it's
it's going to seem that as if like the
background is the same so the screen
should continue but it won't so that's
why I prefer to just create a rectangle
game object that uses a rectangle and
the size of the rectangle is the whole
width and height of this the
canvas all right so one thing I want to
also mention and I forgot to do it is I
told you earlier on that you don't you
don't need to only add
um component so you don't need to only
add components to the array of G uh here
you can also add an object which can
store custom properties you want to
Define so think of it as if you were
using objectoriented programming and you
had your uh various properties
attributes you can Define them here so
for example you could have the HP or
your name Etc and then you pass in the
values you want and then later on you
can access those properties by just
storing that game object so let's say I
store it in my text I guess I'm going to
call it then you can have like a second
text or second text and then here hello
world
again and then
here right below I can do my
text and then access the current text by
doing. text
and then replace that with the new text
with a second text and I can access that
by using my text and then the name of
the property I have defined here so
second text this
is and you can see hello world again
this is pretty powerful because this
allows you to bypass the need to use
classes and while still having code that
looks
clean looks uh understandable and easy
to read and modify
all right so one thing I want to mention
again is that here this the center
component you can use it to have the
center of the canvas uh the positional
component either takes two values like
that or takes a vector two so Vector 2
is something that comes up a lot so here
you can do the same 100 by 100 um so
that's the data structure uh there's no
reason to do it this way instead of just
100 passing 100 by 100 so you should do
that when
when whenever
possible all right so yeah but k. Center
if you look at the return value maybe
not in this editor you're going to see
it returns a vector to all
right okay so now I want to talk about
tags as well so this is going to come
handy in Collision detection so I'm
going to talk about this component later
on so here the next thing I want to
teach is how to when you create game
objects how to get them how to like
basically query them so let's say I
create a bunch of game
objects actually the tags is going to
come in in handy right now so let's say
I create game objects let's say I create
three game
objects they're empty for now and uh
let's say they're all rectangles of 10 x
10 so they're all 10 x 10 squares
so here we go maybe the formatting is
not good you know but it doesn't
matter and for each of them I'm going to
give them a tag so not only can you add
objects in that area of components but
you can also add a string which is going
to act as an identifier for that game
object so here let's say I going to
create a tag called Square and I'm going
to assign it
to all the game objects I created
here square square
square so we have our Square here they
are all in the same position it's very
small so maybe let's scale the canvas
more times so it's clearly
visible uh it's doesn't help much but
does it's not that important you know
maybe off let's offset
them uh okay that I haven't specified
the position so that's why so the
position component here let's keep it at
0 0 by the way if you want a 0 0
position you don't need to specify the
positional component but let's do it
just to be like clear and then let's
copy that over
whoops so let's copy that over to the
other stuff here we go and then here we
go so here let's offset this by 50 and
then here by 100 so now we have our
three squares here this is where the
tags come in handy there's this I'm
going to store my
squares and use a the get method offered
by Klay to query fetch all the game
objects that have the square tag added
to them so the way you do this you do it
Square you pass in the tag and it's
going to return an array so if I use k.
debug.log this is another way of logging
things and then just pass in the Square
when you you can see object object
object object and object object you have
your three objects so the the k.
debug.log is when you want to display
things on the canvas itself you would
use console.log if you want to just
display it in the console here so we
have an array three of them and each of
the objects we have them now one Nuance
I want to talk about the get method here
is what if you had a game object that is
apparent a child of another game object
so let's say I add
this this first game object is the
parent of that second game
object so now if I look at the result by
pressing F12 you can see that we only
have two game objects no longer three if
you want to get all game objects
regardless of there if there are
children of other game objects you need
to pass the second param an object as an
object and specify the recursive
property to being true if you do so what
will happen is if I press F12 you'll
have your array with all your three
objects what happens if you want to use
a component after the fact after having
created your game object so let's remove
all of
this and let's say we have our Square
here as a single game object let's
increase being a 100 by 100 just so
things are CLE
visible and I after having created the
game object later on in my code base I
want to dynamically add a new component
let's say I want to change its color
after the fact for example if the player
clicks on it I'm we're going to later on
see how to handle input where we're
going to see like how to make things
like clicking clicking moving around
pressing keys Etc but for now if you
have your Square here you can and use
the use function uh use method to add a
new component so here I'm going to add
the k. color component that we looked at
uh earlier on and I'm going to put it at
a color RGB of two red so this should be
red so now it will use that comp
component after the fact there's also
the square. unuse and then you can pass
in the the name of the color the
component you use and it's going to
unuse that component so let's say I'm
going to use the
weight something offered by Kaboom
instead of having to use set timer set
forgot the name anyway they capl offers
their own timers so you can just use
this like that so what will happen is
we'll wait 3 seconds before unusing the
color component and the that means the
rectangle will go back to its original
shape here we
go all right so the first param is the
number of seconds to wait and then the
second param is the
function to run when the timer is over
and there's also an asynchronous form of
that function where you use await and
then you just uh call have one paramin
then you would call this they on under
so I'm not going to go over this you can
see in my tutorials by the way all my
Kaboom tutorials are applicable to Kay
so you can follow them just do this the
setup the initial setup differently
install K play instead of KaBoom so now
let's look at how to handle collisions
so
you know to handle collisions let's um
the way I'm going to do it is I'm going
to also introduce the move component
which is something I didn't do so let's
let's dive into that so let's say we
have still R square let's reduce the
size to being 50 by
50 and now this Square I'm going to use
uh remove that it's no longer needed and
I'm going to add in area component to
it so it's going to have a default
hitbox remember you can access the
hitbox uh the debug mode by pressing the
F1 key I think the debug mode is one of
the most powerful and useful thing that
K play offers that I don't see in other
Li libraries for making games you don't
see a as handy debug mode I I would say
so now that we have this and that let's
write our logic so what we're going to
do is we're going to create a second
game object I'm going to call it
Target and it's going to be a small
rectangle 20x 20 and we're going to
place it so I'm going to also specify
the
area and I'm also going to place it at a
position of 30 by zero so maybe not 30
more than that 130 maybe all right so we
have our second Square
here so yeah now that we have that what
I'm going to do
is write our first Collision logic so
how do you do Collision detection in cap
playay there are many methods you can
use but the most important one is the
uncollided method and the uncollided end
method so uncollided end is a method
that is attached to the game object so
let's say I want to check if the target
get has collided so you do on collide
with and then the second param the first
param of that function is the tag of the
game object uh of the game object you
want to check collisions with so here
Target on collide with the square tag so
you can see that you only need a tag for
the second game object you want to check
collisions with and then the second
param is going to be the function that
is going to run when the Collision
happens here I'm just going to debug log
uh Collision happened a message that
says
that so here nothing happens because the
square doesn't move and we need to move
it so the way to move a
square is you can use the move component
so I'm going to maybe have an example
when we're going to use input detection
so I'm going to talk about how to handle
input I mean move things around uh using
the arrow keys and and in that move
component is really used a lot so you do
KLA move and this is the first form of
it and then you can move I actually
don't remember the
um uh what's
[Music]
the
particle let's try let's try it out and
then if there's an issue so 100 by
zero maybe this second param is the
speed I
think all right so if if I put it to
here okay second param is the speed the
SEC the first Pam I think it's a vector
2 and let's say yeah so here Vector 2
comes in handy so the first param of the
move component here is the direction in
which you want the Collision to uh the
the game object to move to towards to
towards and then the second Ram is the
speed so here at the speed of 10 I could
increase that to 50 and then you can see
when it collides you see the message
Collision happen at the bottom of the
screen so yeah uh the reason it's
overlapping is because we Haven to use
the body components so if we were to use
the body component for both of them so
let's say I add the body component
here and I also add the body component
to the Target
they're going to push push it each other
I think yep you can see
that all right so the other uh form of
the on Collide is you can use the on
colide from cap directly but you need to
specify the tag of the first game object
want to check collisions with and then
the second one as well before passing in
the the function I rarely use this form
uh because it's often just more
convenient convenient to use that so
here we go so the other one is Target on
Collide
end and it will run when the Collision
ends and it can be useful when you want
to for example finish an attack uh for
example yeah uh it's it's useful for
example when you want to finish an
attack your player finishes an attack
and then uh how how do you say put back
their swords or something so here I'm
I'm just going to put a debug log
message as well
Collision
ended and then here it's never going to
happen because the objects are pushing
each other because of the body
components but if I remove for example
for Target I remove it you can see
Collision happened and then Collision
ended I did type
over all right so that's uh that's that
now you have an idea how to handle
corations etc etc now now how do you
handle user input so Onkey down on key
press on key release and you can even
have like controller support and Etc I'm
not going to dive into controller
support by the way really this tutorial
is meant as like a starting point but
afterwards you can check the
documentation and by the way if the
documentation is still not complete you
can still refer to the original Kaboom
JS documentation so if I go to Kaboom
JS oops I written I did typo here again
so if I go to Kaboom JS you can search
it and by the way a trick here is that
it's more efficient to search don't use
this it's not that effective you do
contrl F and then you search what you
need for example button and then you'll
get using the buttons here you can see
like the document it's a it's a much
more comprehensive search it's a better
search than this because certain things
don't surface when you use the search
bar here so I recommend still using the
Kaboom JS documentation if there
something missing out in the cap playay
documentation because it's not yet
finished but it's mostly like the same
thing so yeah so now let's see how to
handle user input I'm going to cover the
basic version of it and now K playay has
a new system for uh inputs uh which
allows you to specify buttons for both
multiple different buttons for the
keyboard for the controller and for the
mouse all at the same time time uh
because this feature is an alpha I will
not cover it in this video so I'm going
to wait for uh cap play to release its
3001 version by the way cap the way it
works is that it works in thousands so
uh there were when it was Kaboom it was
Kaboom 2000 then Kaboom 3000 and now
it's Kaboom the version here I think
it's still
[Music]
3.1.7 and then it's the development for
version three 01 is active and is
currently
ongoing all right so now let's load the
bean uh I'm going to use it as the
placeholder asset and I'm going to
create our
player and create the game object for it
and then here I'm going to use that as
the Sprite the bean
Sprite now I'm going to maybe scale it
twice instead all right now here I'm
going to remove the black background
just to make things more
visible and then I'm going to
add the I think that's it
so so just
to handle positions so to handle input
it is preferable to have to use the
Onkey down Onkey press Onkey release
methods directly from the player so the
the game object so the game object offer
those methods but you can also use the
global version of those game objects now
the reason why I'm not actually sure so
if I go to the documentation there is a
guide so the guide section you have the
um so installation basic concepts data
between scenes Etc debug mode so data
between scenes you maybe you should give
that a read I haven't covered it uh it's
very simple so I might cover it later on
but in case I forget uh input binding
which is the new I think this is a new
feature Etc then shaders which is
something I'm not going to cover in this
tutorial but it's very handy to make
your games look good but one thing I'm
going to talk about is the optimizations
so here they recommend that you avoid
the global name St uh no that you where
is it uh use the game object local input
handlers similar to above it's often
better to use local input handlers as
opposed to Global ones uh one thing
though is that it's not explain why uh
why it's better it's just mentioned that
it is so there's probably a reason but I
don't know why and uh if you're a
maintainer of the KL Library please tell
us why uh why and I might ask this in
the Discord by the way uh it's a bit too
late to promote this but the Discord
server is there's a Discord server for K
play and uh the link is going to be in
the description and in the comments I
recommend that you join it because it
where it's where you can ask questions
see questions that were asked by other
people in the past and and really it's
uh the most efficient way to get help uh
I would say let's go back to our example
so here I'm going to call player. Onkey
down and then the Onkey down method in K
play has multiple forms the two main
forms I would say it's either you
specify as the first pram the key you
want to listen on or you just specify
directly the the function that is going
to run when any key is down and it's
going to take care of passing to the
first param of your function fun that
you pass to the unkey down the key
itself this is something I prefer to use
mostly to have the specific there there
to have the specific uh to have this
form instead of the other one where you
you specify a specific key so that you
don't have to call Onkey down multiple
times so but there might be some cases
where it's preferable maybe to use the
first form so in this tutorial I'm just
going to use the second one so here if
you do for example if you console debug
blug k. debug
do log and then log the key you can see
that as I press you can have space up
down left right
Etc so as I said I'm not going to dwell
much on this uh system input system
because it there's a new one that is an
expansion on that and it's going to
probably be more used for professional
games because you want to be able to
specify multiple inputs things at at
once multiple different Keys Etc and on
key down Etc doesn't allow you to do
that so uh just to remind you it's just
go to input bindings this is offered in
the newest version here so you have B
bindings you specify an action then you
can specify various keys for the
keyboard various for the GamePad and
even for the mouse but as I said it's
still in
development okay so on key down you have
the key here and uh what I'm going to do
is I'm going to have a simple if
statement if the key is equal equal to
let's say the right
key then I'm going to take my player and
going to use the move method so you can
use the move method uh not only there
was a move component where you can just
specify immediate movement that happens
as soon as the game object is created
but you can use the move method to
actually move the player in a certain
direction now in conjunction with that
you can as I said pass an an object your
array of component to specify custom
properties and this is where I'd like to
create a speed property and specify a
value and then here I can refer to it by
doing player. speeed and then you can
specify as the first pram the speed that
is going to navigate that the player is
going to navigate on the x-axis and then
uh zero on the y- axis because we just
want to move horizontally so if I press
the the the right arrow key uh maybe I
got it uh got it wrong
uh probably that's because I missing I'm
missing a component Player move is not a
function so this method is only
available if you use the I think the
body component and you can only use the
body component if you use the area
component so we need to add both of them
here this move is not a function
really um what's the
issue um Let me refresh here okay
there's a
this move is not a
function player. move okay well it
should be what am doing
wrong this used to work so ah you
probably need to specify position the
positional component as well and you
need to add your commas so be careful
with that and if I press here we go so
the positional components is mandatory
even if you're not going to specify a
position so it's going to keep to put it
at the top left corner but if you don't
use the positional component you can't
modify the position after the fact
because remember to access the position
once you use the position component you
can use player. pause but if you don't
use the positional component at all even
if you want to like you don't even leave
it empty then player. pause is not going
to work so that mean under the hood it's
not going to be let you move the player
so here I press to the right and I can
move move to the right so that's uh
that's cool uh by the way I just wanted
to Showcase a new blog post I've written
on how to fix diagonal movement into the
top down top down games because in 2D
topown games if you implement uh using a
naive approach what happens is that
you're going to move faster diagonally
than uh on each side so you're going to
move faster diagonally than if you were
to move only to the right for example so
here I've written a block post on how to
fix this um not going to dive into it so
feel free to check my substack the link
is also in the description and hopefully
in the pinned comment as
well so here we go so this is how you do
like on key down same thing with Onkey
press really works the same way the only
difference is that Onkey press which is
written like that it's just going to run
once immediately and then then yep so
you can you will you will only like
Jitter like that so it's useful for
attacks Etc and Y so on key down on key
press and there's also on key release so
for example if you want to only move to
the right when the right key is released
it's going to do that so it's a strange
Behavior but I just want to show show
you how to use those
methods all right so that's that and
then for animations as I've shown you
here in this example you don't have any
but you use the play Method on your
player so imagine that the bean had an
animation so you would play and then
play that animation but for example you
would have another input Handler for
example player on key release which for
example would set back the animation to
default to the default animation so you
would do like player. stop or to stop
the animation or change it with another
animation by play and instead Idol for
example so this is how you would go
about it one thing I want to mention of
course is that it's wise to always check
beforehand what the current animation is
playing and you can do this by having
player. Cur anim and it's going to give
you the name of the current animation
and then you can check it as long as
it's not equal to the animation you want
to actually play right now then you can
play that animation the reason you do
this is because you don't want to
interrupt an animation mid play so let's
say my idol animation is already playing
and is at frame three you don't want to
restart the animation again don't want
that all right so that's that and um yep
now I've already covered how to play
sounds and going forward there is a
couple of things couple of advanced more
advanced features I would say you should
better like watch my Project based
tutorials or just look at the examples
here so one of them is the tween um uh
feature so let me just find it so tween
is very handy it allows you to have like
transitions like that so like
that and then he's out those various
trans transitions they're very useful so
here's an example on how to use them
there's also Mouse press uh and onclick
uh handlers I forgot to mention onclick
is just as onke keep down Onkey press
just you use on click so not much to say
for example here if I click on the
player uh you probably need the area
component for this onclick let's say
it's going
to do k. debug.log and then let's say
test so as all every time I click on the
game object it's going to do this so
yeah you can also use the global k. on
click as well but as I said it seems to
be more performant to use the methods
offered by the game object itself
all right uh so let's go back to Tween
so here I recommend like looking at the
example so
tween has this is a tween so this thing
here is tween it has four one two three
four so maybe I should increase the font
here so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to press F1 and then zoom
in and I do this again
so just ignore all this clutter and look
at this part this is the actual very
important part so the first Pam is the
start value the second so the the
current position of the bean the initial
position of the bean then you have the
destination value you want the final
value to be the mouse position so Mouse
pause is an a play Method you can use to
get the current Mouse position so you do
K if you don't if you're not using
global K playay you do. k so yeah
um and then the duration is in seconds
so you specify a value let's say three
seconds the transition between the
original position and the final value
you want and then the value this is how
the value should be updated this is
where you actually write the function
that is going to change the value
gradually so here we modify the position
of the bean as the value change here and
then the interpolation function there
are many easing types and the way you
access you can do this like that so here
k. eings so if you're using non-global
kaboo and then you have linear you have
a bunch of them they're all documented
in the documentation so that's here if I
do
tween maybe not the reference dock I
think that's the if I do
tween you can have the tween in math
section and then you can see here tween
controller uh not here uh it's not you
can have using out quad you can see that
it's not very convenient here uh if you
look at the Kaboom Jazz documentation
though uh let's say I'm going to remove
that okay boom JS
documentation and then type in here
using contrl F the tween you can go here
and you can see that here in the easing
function you can see like tween
controller uh okay it's not here uh
eings it's the eings thing easing and
then you have the name of the all the
eing functions can use so maybe here as
well in the documentation could have
here if I type in eings you would have
it okay so but you would have all the
name for them so yeah uh for now it's a
work in progress the documentations for
K so feel free to use the kabon Jazz
documentation which are more complete
for now all right so this is how you use
a tween and yep so it's a nice feature
uh to transition things and yep the
other other things for levels so for
making your map and layout there is the
add level method that allows you to
create levels using arrays of strings I
maybe there's a example here the level
example you can see how it's used you
use these symbols and then you for each
symbol you specify a game object I
personally never use this I never use it
because it's not performant but I do
recognize that it is handy I used it in
a tutorial and uh my JavaScript
platformer tutorial this was be before I
figured out how to use til so here again
my substack is very useful here because
I've written a whole post on how to use
tile with kabon JS it's the exact same
logic for CA where you can use tile
which is an external program where you
can draw your your levels and then you
can import that into your as a Json file
then import that into your your game and
here I show the code and explain it so
hope you yeah this I'm going to just
link the general G Legend Dev substack
here and then you can go and search for
those
posts all right maybe I'm I'm put the
link for each things though so maybe
yeah just to be more convenient we have
covered the most important parts um for
the shaders I just want to give you a
taste just look at the examples you can
change the color Etc there are more
interesting examples in the playground I
don't know if they're here though uh
ghost hunting what is that
oh there there are new examples so
that's nice uh so yeah feel free to
check the the these examples there are
pretty a lot of pretty cool things you
can take inspiration from for your games
so for example this uses shaders and
this very impressive very nice so if you
do up and down you can have various
different effects even like the the
light Etc so that's that's nice so yeah
I'm not very familiar with shap shaders
I don't know the Shader land glsl I
haven't learned shaders that's why I
didn't want to cover it but I know how
to use them how to load them and a k
play for example so maybe I'm going to
dive in and read the book of shaders
which is the recommended material
usually shown to beginners for this uh
maybe not beginners but people wanting
to learn on the subject all right so now
the last thing is
to yeah there there there's two things
uh one is the state machines so how to
program an AI enemy AI Etc I think it's
going to be too involved to code in this
tutorial and maybe there's an example
here the code here it uses on state
enter so to use a state machine what is
a state machine it's a way to program an
AI you specify various States so here
Idol attack and move and then you
specify the default State and then here
what happens that you enter into the
default State and then you have have a
Handler for your your States for example
when the enemy you enters the idle State
you will run some logic and then move on
to another state and this is how AI is
done so for example this ghost first it
is in the move state it start moving and
then at one point it's going to remain
idle and then after having remained
idled it's going to move on to a attack
state so really I recommend just looking
up this code I in my my Metroid Vania
tutorial I have written the code I did
the AI for enemies and Etc so this
something a bit too involved for me to
do here uh here is the most basic
example that is going to give you a
taste of what it's like to code in EN AI
so yeah I recommend diving in on that
and then finally the last um feature I
want to talk about is
the uh what is it's the trigger custom
event in Kaboom Jaz so custom events are
a way to make your code cleaner and so
you can trigger those events they're
similar to signals in kodo so I
recommend reading that uh that blog post
here custom event in kabo JS which is
applicable to KL I might actually edit
the titles and put in kl/ kabj so that's
that and that's it I hope this tutorial
was useful to you uh yep so feel free to
if you want to dive into project you can
using just the knowledge in this
tutorial and using the documentation and
the playground you can actually start
working on your first game in K play by
yourself if you want to see how we do
things a bit more advanced you can
follow one of my tutorials and yep so
I'm hoping to see you in future videos
so subscribe if you want uh so if you
want to learn how to make a how to
transform your C playay game into a
desktop downloadable game you can watch
the previous tutorial I did on that so
yeah thanks for watching